do you ever have a date where you just
think okay I can't be asked to do
anything I'm not going for a run I'm not
stretching I'm doing nothing every day
so you have the thought but you don't
have the day every day ever let yourself
have a day when you just watch Netflix
never I can't do it I can't do it there
may be some days I get up with poopy
pants and I'm like you know what man
[__] this man like what am I training
for yeah I have no race in the docket
why am I having this such a structured
life why and I'm like you know what I'm
good I'm done I retire every day I'm
done with this [__] and I sit around and
say okay and then this is my thought
process so you want to be normal so you
just want to be like everybody else that
roams the world not knowing the power
that's in them being fine but being
mediocre you want to go back to who you
were huh David
and you have that conversation with
yourself every day not every day it's
those bad days yeah we have no idea how
talented they truly are now I'm talking
about Talent like some god-giving
ability sometimes you have to hone you
have to work on and you have to harness
yourself and they just walk around on
their phone clueless to how powerful
they are hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos videos because the
thing that saved me as an entrepreneur
was watching the stories of other
successful entrepreneurs and I learned
from their advice I learned from their
motivation and honestly I have no idea
where I would be if I didn't have those
videos to inspire me I still need them
for myself today too and I hope that
they can inspire you as well so today
let's get some incredible motivation
from the one and only David Goggins
enjoy
I believe that you have to build belief
belief is like there's an after-school
special belief where the mom says
believe in yourself and that's all great
but there's also a built belief
and the built belief is one where you
are constantly like for me I came from a
bad place How I build belief is through
the the daunting tasks
I put myself through so that's proof
positive that I can
so it correlates and that's how this kid
I once thought I was
belief by saying hmm
I was in three hell weeks
I went to Ranger school
I tried out for Delta selection
undeniable stack of proof that is proof
whenever you think you can't
confidence comes from the thing that you
built
you must build belief you must build
confidence it came like hey
um I'm Gonna Knock that [__] out
you gotta look over here and say
I can knock that down
is belief it is built on what you put in
to yourself This Allure that you have
where it's with anything any type of
keynote from David Goggins any type of
video from David podcast what do you
think it is what do you think it is that
attracts people to your content I think
it's my take it or leave it kind of
mentality
where I don't really think about your
feelings I don't really care about what
you think or what you think about me or
if you're soft if you're weak if you're
hard if you're an alpha if whatever the
hell you are I just don't really care
and I'm gonna say what I believe is
going to get you better it may make you
pissed off at me in the interim
but in the long term if you really think
about what I'm saying I'm saying things
to you that I had to listen to
and you know tell myself and it's just
sometimes hard truth sucks what's your
morning routine every morning without
fail the first thing I do is I run
without fail I haven't missed a day of
running since 2016. okay so I get up I
do that four days out of the week I go
to the gym and every single night for
five and a half years I stretch out for
at least two hours that was a Killer
part of the book every I haven't that is
that's where I so when you go so hard
mentally physically mostly spiritually
you have to have time set aside to quiet
and recover recovery is Big the Mind
especially the mind and the body this is
my time there's no phone calls there's
no emails the world does not exist
because I have to get ready for tomorrow
get the body opened up why because as I
won't get you know
it was awesome but your body's getting
tight yeah you go hard Tom yeah a lot of
people go hard what happens is that
stress starts to tighten up that psoas
muscle hip flexor is so uh lower back
you got back problems all of a sudden
you have no idea why it's all tightness
it's all tightness man because you're
you're constantly charged and going hard
your insecurities your fears pain
suffering whatever whatever your mind
starts to feel uncomfortable
your brain tells you it's time to quit
we are done let's now go to our
comfortable spot where we feel good
about ourselves
so the 40 rule is just that we are
leaving so much on the table because our
mind has control over us
versus us having control over our minds
why is the book called can't hurt me
there's a lot of reasons why
um is that that the childhood the
upbringing from the the dad is childhood
and it's life uh because basically the
most important conversation you'll ever
have is the one you have with yourself
you wake up with it you walk around with
it you go to bed with it eventually you
act upon it
if life is beating you down yeah and
it's hurting you and your internal
dialogue is man life is kicking my ass
yeah
you know what when I was in still
training when I was in Ranger school
when I was in all these when I was
growing up I started realizing man
people I can't hurt me mentality if
you're getting bullied like I got
bullied if you're struggling if you're
failing if you're following that
whatever falling out in life
if your mind is telling you hey we're in
the fight we're not going anywhere you
can't hurt me man what you bring on me
no matter how bad life is I'm gonna be
right here standing right in the middle
of the ring and the ring is the Ring of
Life yeah
it's just it's just the Mantra that you
say to yourself like hey you know what
whatever man bring it bring it become
very dangerous when you when when you
have this idea that you can't be hurt or
killed that's right most of this
generation quits the second they get
talked to
you did this wrong you did this wrong or
they get yelled at it's so easy it says
you know I mean to be great nowadays
because everybody else is most people
are weak
this this is a softened generation so if
you have any mental toughness
any any ability if you have any fraction
of self-discipline the ability to not
want to do it but still do it people
have a a hard thing to understand I hate
to run and it makes me so crazy it
doesn't anymore people well why do you
run if you hate it what are you talking
about
I don't want to take showers and eat
either I hate that too the whole that's
a life man
that and and it it wasn't until I
changed that mentality that I became
somebody um I hated going to school so
guess what I was dumbest
that's what one plus one is two
but if you can get through to doing
things that you hate to do
on the other side is greatness
that's what people understand by me
running I am callous in my mind I'm not
training for a race
I'm training for life
I'm training for the time when I get
that two o'clock in the morning call
that my mom is dead or something happens
tragic in life I don't fall apart
I'm training my mind and my body my
spirit so it's all one so I can handle
what life is going to throw at me
because the life I've lived
it throws a whole bunch at you
and if you're not physically immensely
prepared for that
you're just gonna crumble and you're
good for nobody you said I can be me
the second you said I can cuss and be me
and cussing people I say man you cuss
all the time why well I hate to say it
the best way for me to get how I feel
across
I can't sit and say you know what yeah I
went through hell weekend man it was it
was really hard
no that
takes your damn Soul rips it inside out
and then they say now we're going to
start
it it allows me to express right where I
was at at a point of my life if I don't
give you all of me why the hell am I
here
why how will you learn from me people
take so much offense to me you will
never learn from people if we always tap
dance around the truth oh God I love
that we tap dance around the truth by
finding the right word so I don't hurt
you because you have thin skin no
tighten up people it's okay trust me
it's okay you might be called [__] one
day
it's okay
you might be called some Jewish word or
some your gay word it's okay let them
call you that what are you going to do
now they don't own your life how are you
going to control that now how are you
going to flip it upside down and say
Roger that now I'm going to harness this
and you'll read about me years from now
if you could define happiness for you
what would that be it's overcoming
yourself yeah yeah at all costs whatever
that takes to be at the point of your
life where you don't care about being
judged you can be in a room of a million
people and they all hate you and you
walk in and you go like this
because not because you're angry at them
because you know yourself
inside and out and you know that you've
put yourself through hell to be where
you're at today you've walked a walk
you've talked to talk and you've walked
the walk
and that's to me what it's all about
it's all about putting those boots on
the ground and getting after it every
day and once you do that you have a
feeling about yourself that no one can
ever take away or even understand yeah
it starts with the accountability mirror
and it starts with you putting a Post-It
note up on the accountability mirror I
am fat
I am this I am that
and then put another post note beside
that you're fat on the ways how you're
going to start to change that
and then every morning you go brush your
teeth wash your face whatever you're
gonna do look at that poster note
and look at it and make sure it bothers
you yeah yeah yeah I love that dude it
has to bother you if if being fat does
not bother you you are never gonna
change it has to bother you that you're
not the smartest person in the room yeah
it has to bother you that you are lazy
if it doesn't bother you there's nothing
anyone can do for you be disappointed
with yourself that's right that's okay
it's okay to be that way there are a lot
of people that are listening right now
that either dealing with this very issue
that we're talking about when we finally
left Buffalo after all the physical and
mental beatings that my dad handed out
we left Buffalo and I went to a to me
even worse environment I went through a
very small town in Brazil Indiana where
there was about five black families and
in 1995 the KKK marched in our fourth of
July parade
so that being said it paints Brazil
Indiana that you know that's the town
I'm talking about in a very bad light
and there were a lot of good people in
this small town so I want to make that
very clear but what happens is when you
come from a very Broken Foundation yeah
your mind only sees hate and evil yeah
there was one time I was in my sophomore
year walked in my Spanish class to get
my notebook open my notebook up and
inside the notebook
someone drew a little character of me in
a stick figure hanging from you know
like that like a noose yeah or like a
Hangman game
at this time in my life I was a
sophomore and I had about fourth grade
reading level because I cheated all
through school right all through school
I cheated because I realized I was going
to get put in a special school right so
I found a way to get by and that's how I
got by right so what I'm getting at is
all this between my stepfather getting
murdered or soon to be stepfather get
murdered all these things compounded
into the lowest of low self-esteem so
what started happening was I started
lying
I became a amazing liar because I wanted
people to like me yeah when you come
from a society like I did
I had zero self-esteem and I feared
things I had zero self-confidence and I
was looking for anything I could that I
could gravitate to so it was lying yeah
but that's when I realized and it was a
long process that without having
self-esteem you are done yeah that's the
number one thing you have to have in
your life so the one second decision is
I had to live through that one second
decision several times during this race
so this race
took me a hundred and some hours okay
and this is what people don't get
for you to finish that race even though
I dnf'd I still finished in the time
so there's a lot of pride in that what I
do in that one second because we all
think about quitting it's hard
but what you have to do in that one
second is hard to process information
during pain
because that pain takes over
and you can't think rationally
you're thinking about fight or flight
save yourself that's not a rational
thought it's not a thought that's going
to get you through
hard times
most people fail that one second so what
happens what I do in that one second and
there's a bigger process to all this but
in that one second
I physically stayed in that water
because if I get out of the water I quit
so I physically stay in the water but
mentally
I'm on the beach with instructors and
the instructors it's cold outside so
they got these Parkers on they got their
cup of Joe and they're warm because
they've been through it so now it's your
turn to go through it
so Millie I get back with them I'm still
in the water physically but mainly I'm
back with you I'm chilling I got my
Parker on and now I'm thinking logically
because I'm warm now mentally I'm warm
I've taken that one second
let's not quit yet guys let's think
about your options
where are you going to end up if you
quit this where are you going to go
where are you going to say to yourself
because you know you're going to get
warm the second you get out of this
water you're gonna take a shower
and you can be warm and you could be and
in five days you could be out so I start
thinking logically
I calm my brain down because your brain
just wants to get out ring the bell put
your helmet down get warm and then you
really
and these are the things you have to
think about the one second decision
so that's that's all about it's about
gaining control of your mind
putting things back in the proper
perspective
and then saying
I really do want to be here
and I'm gonna have a bunch of these one
seconds through this 130 hour Journey
and I have to learn to control these
because if I fail one of these one
seconds I will not be a seal I will not
be a doctor I will not be a lawyer I
will not be whatever it is so that's how
important that one second decision is
it's all about your mind taste control
you you have to say you I run this
and that's what that's all about when
you talk about the importance of having
the right people in the Foxhole with you
how do you know who the right people are
you know what that's that was something
to me a lot of years to figure out
you know you're the right people in your
Foxhole
when you're waking up at three o'clock
in the morning you're going to bed at
midnight and you're waking up at three
and no one says is this smart to do you
need some time off you need to take a
break
when I start hearing that well I know
what I'm doing to myself
I was behind the power curve man when
everybody starts off in first grade
I had them negative grades
I started off in the dungeon but I I had
to dig out of the damn grave to get the
first grade so now you're 20 years old
well everybody graduated a high school
in Austin man I gotta make time up
so while people think 24 hours is one
day for me it's three four five days
I gotta make up time I'm behind I gotta
go to summer schools in my mind
when who's with me realizes this gotta
go to summer school in his mind he's got
to make up time he needs 22 hours of the
24.
and they just get it he's trying to go
somewhere
you are the right person for my Foxhole
I don't want to hear no about resting I
can't rest right now I'm hearing about
what I'm doing to myself I know what I'm
doing to myself
did you see how I came up I gotta catch
up now
and that's what life is about sometimes
you are raised in a position where you
are behind
we have to make that time up
I'm sorry it may be inhumane you may be
unbalanced it may not look right to you
I don't
it's the situation that life put me in
and I need people to say but I don't
want to give at three in the morning I
need my life that see me go to bed at 12
and wakes me up at three
saying you need to get done
that's the Foxhole I don't need
critiquing I need pushing I need pulling
I need anger I need passion I need Drive
I need the man those bad days I don't
need somebody in my ear saying
man
because then that's all a person needs
is that support can go a lot of ways man
I mean a thousand dollars a month 300
pounds just I can't do any of this stuff
yeah these people are better than me
yeah so the first thing is that's the
first big problem right there first big
problem is that you have put a lot of
people above you yeah put no one above
you yeah no one wherever you but if if
you believe in something say that again
say that again because that's you know
but you know but the the man the people
that make more money the people that are
better looking the ones that are on
social media and they're so good at this
I put God above me besides that there's
no one better than me got it you have to
become an equal so this I look at it
if you're playing and I talked about it
at your conference if you're playing
Roger Federer yeah okay
be before you get on the court with
Roger Federer he's the best of all time
yeah but you're also a professional
tennis player man yep you're forgetting
your own resume yep so once you get on
the court let's say It's a grand slam
it's five sets hopefully if You Can Go
the Distance with this guy yeah but
before you even bounce the ball to serve
it you're down two sets because while
you look across and you're playing Roger
Federer but guess what you hit a good
shot on Roger Federer in the third set
and you realize I can play with this
but it's too late yeah you gave up two
sets before you gone to court
you gotta stop giving up two sets before
the game begins and we do that already
my dad really helped create this I'm not
giving him credit yeah like oh he was a
great dad like clap my hands for his ass
he helped create this because he was
just that he was a a devil you know he
was a guy that had to be very insecure
very beat down something had happened to
him when he was younger because the the
way he treated me my brother my mom was
just horrible so he would beat us my mom
my brother my me and I'm not talking
like oh you got in trouble something to
give you whipping when he would he was
drunk okay so whenever he woke up man he
woke up drinking went to bed drinking
and that's just how it was I mean he'd
get drunk he just got violent so my mom
caught my dad cheating we got home about
four o'clock in the morning about seven
eight years old
and I hear some Ruckus outside my room
as I'm getting ready to bed down for the
night and my mom and dad are outside my
room because there's a staircase right
there
and my dad is smacking the hell out of
my mom and knocks her almost unconscious
where she's kind of out of it you know
she's kind of loopy she falls down he
grabs it by her hair and drags you down
the stairs by her hair
and so at this age I'm still thinking
man you know what should I do man like
you know I'm scared but then something
in me saying you gotta go and do
something oh my God but I'm scared of
death of this guy he'd been beaten
inside me since I can remember and I
mean like lay me out for nothing
and I'm sure thinking man okay man like
I what am I gonna do so my brother
he and I were very different when my
brother would see the fighting he would
go to this room and hide yeah I didn't
do that I always stuck around so this
time I stuck around I decided to help
her out so go on the stairs and I jump
on his back and literally he tells my
mom you're raising a gangster and she's
like on the floor and he's almost
smiling almost like proud
but that smile went to a frown pretty
quick and he beat the living hell out of
me and he beat me literally from my neck
down to my ankles like black and blue so
the next morning
um I was gonna go to school half today
my mom woke up and she pulled the covers
back and when she saw was how bruised
that was
and so when she pulled the covers back
and saw a bruised that was I'll never
forget looking at her face because she
used to write letters for me you know
for me my brother to miss PE because we
were so bruised up from getting beaten
so you know how he's sick or whatever
and so you know she was lying a lot for
my dad
so this particular day she didn't write
a letter but when I laid in the bed and
looked at my mom and she put the covers
back I'll never forget looking at her
face and her face is tattooed in my
brain and while I say that
um this past year I got the VFW award
for americanism award and if you google
David Goggins VFW award I'm in for the 5
000 veterans and I'm getting this
amazing award John McCain got it and I'm
up here thinking I'm a freaking this
award this is amazing it's for giving
back and also having a great military
career
and I could give this six minute long
speech and I'm up there man I'm talking
and I'm thinking I'm thinking people who
help me out I get to my mom she's
sitting back you know she's sitting
right here on stage behind me
and I haven't cried in 30 years I came
to picture it haven't cried in 30 years
I don't do that and I turned around and
said and I and I want to thank my mom
for um
not picking me up when I was knocked
down but teaching me how to get up
because she never picked me up ever and
because her circumstances sucked yeah so
anyway I looked back and I said that and
I got done I didn't get a chance to say
it I looked at her eyes in my head went
right back to her face when she saw me
bruised up
and that that [__] me up and for 58
seconds look at the video and you'll see
me my head's down and I'm sobbing wow
and I'm in front of 5 000 vets and the
guy who was who was hosting the thing
had to come up to me
and like put his hand on my back and I
was just destroyed overcome with emotion
and then 58 seconds go by and I get up
and I deliver this speech
and so I tell you that because life my
life tattooed me how does someone who's
ordinary or listening or watching get
more committed achieve more success the
biggest thing you have to do is shut off
technology
you have to go dark remember about that
is you have to be quiet in your mind get
away from people we love being around
people we love talking we love we love
parties we love all that
it's okay to be alone
it's also okay to be unhappy
it's okay to be unhappy sometimes man
it's okay to say you know what man I'm
so you gotta go to the truth first who
are you
get get really accountable
and say okay who am I what's the truth
about me
get to that dark place in your mind
figure out it may take months it may
take years figure out your purpose
figure out what you want to be in life
and then from there
okay I have my purpose it may take a
long time no one knows their purpose
because it's too loud
finds your purpose from there all right
you gotta start planning
people love the planning phase because
it's very comfortable then from the
planning phase you gotta go to execution
so the execution phase where we all hate
because that's where the real work
begins and that's when the failure
happens and the failure and the failure
but you know that's that that's kind of
how you have to do it yeah yeah you have
to tap into suffering every day of your
life because we have so much scarring
that we have to clean up
you have to look at suffering as almost
like I look at failure
to succeed you must fail
in failure and in suffering all the
answers are in there all the answers to
all the test questions the test is your
life
all the answers are in there you don't
have to live in suffering and pain and
failure all the time
you have to learn I need to visit it
like people hate working out
you're only going to visit working out
maybe an hour a day 23 other hours of
the day you're not in it but how you
become in shape is you must visit
suffering visit working out one hour a
day visit suffering one hour a day visit
your past failures one hour a day the
relationship with it is the answers are
in there
they they are in there within the
suffering go in there
they're called the live autopsy the live
autopsy how you find out someone died
they crack you open after you're dead
how you can live is do it while you're
alive go back in your brain crack it
open while you're alive don't wait until
you're dead to figure out why you died
do it while you are living
go in there go into the suffering go
into the pain of your life and say why
did this suck for me so bad
why am I afraid of all this stuff why
have I shut down the whole world
I guarantee I'll tell you why you shut
down the whole world it's in these Nooks
of the suffering within your brain in
the scarring
are all the answers
to why you are on the couch feeling
sorry for yourself
they lie within the scars
visit them for at least an hour a day
study them and then you'll find out more
about yourself you will then grow so
don't look at us every day I suffer go
into it an hour a day learn from
yourself learn from Life learn from your
failures learn from your insecurities
learn from your self-doubt don't just
say I'm afraid to jump off an airplane
what makes you afraid of it study it
that's why I studied my mind why I
became so powerful in the mind because I
realized I was weak
so instead of running away from the mind
I dove into and say what is making me
weak when you get to where you want to
go in life you finally get there you
finally reached that point
and you're there
and you're happy as hell
realize this
you're not there yet
um
when you get that feeling that you
arrived
be afraid
right be truly afraid
because now you start to do this slowly
die slowly die either you're getting
better or you're getting worse
you're not staying the same yeah so when
you get to where you think the journey
has ended
and you're sitting back and you're like
I arrived I'm on Mount Everest I climbed
29 0-29 yeah
best thing to do is fall back down that
damn Mountain as fast as you can and
start climbing find the next climb find
the next climb yeah
we all have these voices in our head
we'd like to not listen to them
the one that Comforts us and keeps us
nice and warm and cuddly and gives us
cookies and milk at night time we like
that voice that voice the one where you
want to always share with you why people
don't like to listen to me a lot some
people do some people don't the only
thing that changes you is being real
so basically you know I had to have the
courage to go back in it because nothing
was getting done I kept on going to that
nice cuddly voice in my head saying you
know what you don't need to do this
too much work man you've earned this you
deserve this and that mentality got me
to 297 pounds fat out of shape to me a
loser to me making a thousand dollars a
month and making a ton of mistakes
because mistakes happen on the easy side
of life
you take the easy Road the easy path
there's a lot of mistakes over there the
hard journey you don't make too many
mistakes over here because it's too hard
you don't want to repeat it mine is so
powerful and I didn't realize it I went
through three hell week's range of
school Delta Force selection all this
stuff this incident I'm gonna explain to
you right now is where I realized we are
only at 40 percent of what we are
capable of
here I am right I did to this race
called badwater 135. I Googled the 10th
hardest races in the world what came up
crazy race in Death Valley
summertime 135 miles
I knew nothing about ultra running
I thought you would like you know camp
out run 20 miles then one day they run
20 miles again until you get 135 miles
had no idea what I was doing
call the race director up he's like hey
have you run 100 miles
I was like what in a week or what what
are you talking about
he's like no in 24 hours or less I said
no he goes you got qualify to get in
this race
you have to run a hundred miles in 24
hours or less
he was trying to call my bluff I call
him up on a Wednesday he goes hey
there's a race in San Diego on Saturday
where's the 24-hour race where you run
around you know a track a one mile track
for 24 hours and if you get 100 miles
I will consider you in my race
it really helps to be smart people
and I was not smart in this situation
I said oh I did the math it's about a 14
something minute mile
I can do that
anyway I show up on Saturday with the
blue lawn chair Ritz crackers mild Plex
and my ex-wife
and every mile I'm going to see her I'm
gonna grab some Ritz crackers and some
mileplex
I don't know what the hell I'm doing but
it's Bliss that whole ignorance is bliss
thing
so I get to 70 miles pretty damn fast
I guess 70 miles in like 12 13 hours
we think happens to your body we haven't
trained for that kind of mileage
a lot of bad things about those in good
shape it was amazing so I hadn't gone to
bathroom at all
I sit down big mistake
I sit down this blue lawn chair I sit
down looking at my ex-wife I'm seeing
like three or four of her
I'm like oh this is not good
so I'm trying to play it off
because
I know where I'm about to go
so I'm sitting there and when you
haven't gone to the bathroom or
dehydrated your nutrition is all jacked
up
you sit down you gotta go to the
bathroom now
I'm sitting there
and I'm all jacked up
and I'm like okay
how in the world am I gonna I got 30
miles to go
I should quit
but I didn't
what I started doing
through this whole process
was I started to study myself in the
dark times
so instead of just quitting real fast
I see no I'm going to quit but not right
now
so I sat back for a second
and I said let me get some water let me
hydrate let me clean myself up a little
let me get some nutrition
I wasn't dizzy
it's okay
my feet are all messed up
let me see if I can walk
I'm gonna walk one mile and then I'll go
home that'll be a great accomplishment
for me 71 miles
so I took this massive thing and I
started breaking it down into small
chunks
and as I started breaking it down to
small chunks I started realizing
maybe I'll walk one more mile
but at the pace I was walking
I wasn't gonna make the time
so this is when I realized that whole 40
percent rule those you who would you
know red can't hurt me you understand it
basically the 40 rules we have a
governor on our brains like a governor
on a car
a car may say 130 but if you put a
girlfriend on the car it can only go
one-on-one
we do the same thing to our brains
I was born with limited Horizons
morning our side of the tracks I didn't
think I could be anybody
so my governor was myself
so once you take that governor off you
have Limitless Horizons
so here I am now sitting in this chair
walk 75 I'm at 80 miles but I'm not
going back to time
most amazing thing happens
the brain the mind the soul the spirit
it all connected it's never happened
before like this in my entire life
I ran the next 19 miles
I ran about 10 minute mile I finished
101 miles
in 19 hours and six minutes
I'm going to save you how the story ends
because it is real foul it ends in the
tub with me peeing Coca-Cola out of
myself it was blood
and it was the best film I had in my
entire life I'm not sadistic but when
you push yourself to that level and
accomplished something you thought was
impossible what happens to your body and
mind is something I can't really even
explain when I left I was young
I had a young man's a young kid's point
of view on my father
so when I was 22
at 300 pounds I went back to see my dad
because I want to make sure that what I
saw at eight
is the same this is my father
I don't want to not talk to my father no
matter what he did no matter what I saw
but was it through a young kid's eyes so
at 22 I went back
and I was able to examine him at a as a
as a man
as a fragile man that I was sure I was
able to examine him
and through this process by this so by
this point in my life I was examining
myself
and realized I have a whole mess of
problems Big Time some
were from him some were for people that
bullied me a lot were for me
and in knowing how messed up I was I was
able to examine everybody around me
I examined him
and I examined him to know my God the
insecurities that you must have the
problems that you must have inside of
you
I don't want to have those
I come from my father
I have what he has
um
and I didn't want to be him
why he made fun of me my brother why he
beat the hell out of me my brother my
mom
it comes from a dark place an insecure
dark dark place why he womanized why he
sold prostitutes while he ran all the
stuff he did
a good human being
doesn't need to do that a fulfilled
human being
doesn't need to break anyone down all
they do is Want to Build You Up
so anybody you meet
that calls you out of your name
that bullish that messes you up that
that makes you feel
not lifted they are dealing with
something deep rooted
yeah you have to have a tough tone with
some people to help them out there's a
difference you have to be hard I'm hard
on people but it comes from a good place
yeah
the biggest lesson he taught me was how
not to be
and that's why I had to fix
what I was
because insecurities make everybody
around you feel like hell and that's the
one thing
I did not want anyone to feel like
that's why I judge no one tons of whites
have called me [__] I've been tons of
people have hurt me
I judge no one because I know where it
comes from
I know you
I was once you
that's why now the place I'm at
you get to get out of jail free card you
need to help yourself you ain't bullying
me man right you're fine you're I'm good
whatever you throw at you I'm good
you're like I know what's wrong with you
I always want you right
so I started to examine people
examine myself examine my darkness
realizing how I cannot be but I got it
from examining him
saying I cannot be that you're going to
find peace from going to war with
yourself because we all got people look
at me ever the reason why my story
resonates with people because I don't
hide I'll tell you exactly the [__] I am
I will admit to it people are great at
hiding so they wanted this fine piece no
you got you gotta take your
fixers in you don't just shove it under
rug fix it and then you'll find some
peace later I'll work with the guy who's
in a business like this for five years
I'm not gonna mention his name yeah he
called me up five years ago and say I
want you to work with me yeah his job a
big day for them was if you had five
meetings
and 40 calls 40 that was like according
to their big business plan that was a
day yeah he said I want to make more
money
um all this this bug you know it's just
it's bogging me down I said this is your
day
five meetings and forty calls like what
do you do you start at 10 and you got
four and and and this company you work
for says that this is a great day this
is what we want
I had this guy no
one day he made a thousand cold calls it
had seven meetings yeah so his new Norm
which is now the company like how did
you become he made a hundred thousand
went to making six hundred thousand
dollars in three years yeah that's
that's the jump he had just because his
mindset changed because the company put
the
this is what is a good day a good day is
40 calls five meetings I said you're
comparing yourself with mediocre people
Tango Bingo do not run with mediocre
people I'm going to tell you how to beat
these mediocre people this is your new
300 dials in eight meetings yeah
and his whole world changed now 300 just
another day yeah what I'm most impressed
with is training the brain would you say
to those of us that are listening and
watching today that every time you would
get through a day of hell week or just a
day of training whatever it was that the
Mind does almost like a muscle The Voice
does change and you can train the
negative voice
the mind as you know is not a muscle but
it almost is yeah it really is if you
stop going to the gym right your muscles
will atrophy yeah if you stop training
your brain same thing will happen so I
learned to callous over I did 4030
pull-ups in 17 hours to break the
guestbook of world's records your hands
become very calloused
calluses protect your hands
what I've learned to do is through
mental hardening is callous my mind I
had a victim's mentality I learned to
callous My Mind Over the victim's
mentality
and you have to be willing to put
yourself in very difficult situations at
all times to be able to do that so my
big takeaway of life is
if you're constantly taking the easy way
out you never accomplish your mind I was
at MIT
they called a person like me to MIT to
speak to some of the biggest head guys
on the planet oh yeah these guys oh
brains so awesome I was on this panel
and I you know I'll talk about it in my
introduction of my book
and all these brainiacs were there and
they called me in like you say
I didn't go to college for this but
they're all theorists
I'm a practitioner that's why I asked
you absolutely that's the difference and
so they're all sitting there all these
great smart Minds from MIT are asking
these brilliant guys questions I ain't
say a word I'm like I'm intimidated
right but I know that half of what
they're saying is wrong because with
these theorists that even though they're
very smart what these theorists did was
they took a poll on normal people
and this is what you get of course this
is what we cannot do so theorists love
telling you what we cannot do this is
what we can do
so one person in the crowd asked me a
question why aren't you saying anything
I said pretty much I disagree with
almost everything up here on this panel
because I'm living proof that everything
that they're pretty much saying is not
true that's right because you were an
average person I was a below below sure
sure below average person I was a
chameleon living in life who right could
barely get by so I know that they were
taking the normal mindset of people they
weren't talking about the one percenters
the people who wanted like there's no
tomorrow and so that's what I started
realizing was we have theorists
and we have practitioners so what's in
my book is from going into the to the
dungeon
and when you're in those points where
you want to quit
and not quitting and seeing how the mind
starts to operate in those moments of
fear anxiety self-doubt insecurities and
that's where you learn to fix it yeah
you don't fix it in 72 Degree weather
right drinking the milkshake watching TV
you fix it by going into the environment
the problem that most of us have is we
think that we're all alone
we think they were the only ones going
through all this stuff I thought it most
of us think that if you're fat which I
was fat for a while you think you're the
only fat person in the world your your
vision becomes very narrowed
and what happened to me was all I did
was I peeled back
I pulled back and I was able to get on
top of a Mountaintop in my head and when
you're high on that mountain you have a
great you have a great vantage point
and I was able to look down at the world
and we are all of us are jacked up some
of us hide it better than others but
we're all jacked up and once you realize
that you know you got to come out of
your shell you got to accept who you are
you got to accept the demons that life
gave you that maybe you gave you whoever
gave them to you you got to accept that
you gotta be able to look him in the
mirror look him in the eyes say okay I'm
gonna start fixing these things but if
you think that you're by yourself
the reality of your life becomes very
very horrible and you're not we are all
jacked up and once you realize that man
you just
it's like whatever
you know you don't even look at the
crowd anymore you look at your own race
you do your own race you do your own
thing and you finally found out who
you're supposed to be in this life what
does a morning look like for you at the
moment if you've got a routine of some
kind yes I run every single morning so
that's time you up when you're waking up
I'm up about five five thirty so every
morning starts with the Run
and that's because that's the one thing
I hate to do more than anything in the
world
so that's like my cup of coffee
and I'm all about armoring yourself
so the second you leave your house
and the second you open your phone you
are now letting in poison in cancer
so I make sure a lot of things you can't
avoid
so as I get up I start to armor plate my
mind and body like a person's going to
war you put your body armor on that's
what I'm doing on that run
I'm waking up and I'm giving myself all
this armor so when I come out in the
world now look at that phone I'm ready
I'm not waking up late I'm not rushing
around I'm not disorganized because I
know I'm gonna get hit in the mouth
there's a there's an art to getting hit
in the mouth
and that is why these things are
important you have to wake up and you
have to give yourself belief you have to
give yourself confidence so that it
starts with that run anybody not just
Navy Seals but anybody that can
accomplish anything that is hard
the only separator is is that they
really want to be there
there's some people that get inspired in
that inspiration moves them to try to do
something but the inspiration
is very high right now in this nice
environment we're in a nice environment
the oceans out there I'm talking to you
if I want to go to the refrigerator and
get something to drink eat I can
I watch a movie about some badasses
you're inspired but the second you're
not in this environment
and you're actually doing what inspired
you
that suck factor is not real
you can't just get off your couch and
get a shake or get a box of donuts or
turn the TV you're now there and only
those people who have been there a
million times in their minds
and have lived in that water and have
suffered a million times and realized my
legs may break um
my knee may break my bones will hurt I
will be the coldest I've been in my life
I will be miserable mm-hmm and accept
that
because what happens is we when you get
in a horrible situation in life you're
mine I caught my one second decision
when you get a horrible situation in
life your mind immediately says get the
out of here everybody's does even if you
want to be there
but it starts to have all these
different questions in your mind that
one second it says okay why are you here
why are you doing this why this why that
and then you start to say yourself if
you don't want to be there that bad I
have a beautiful wife at home man why
the [__] am I doing this man like this
is stupid this is gonna get these guys
injured like like they're gonna pay for
this for the rest of their lives I'm not
gonna break my body up to do this your
mind starts to say yeah this is stupid
but if you have if you are already
knowing that this is going to happen to
you you have all the answers to these
questions that your mind starts to give
you when you're in suffer mode let's say
for some giggles I'm training for 100
mile race yeah let's say a tour just for
something giggles I'm trading for 100
mile race right okay good so let's say
I'm trading for 100 mile race
and I get to mile 50 yeah and I feel
like
and like everybody else my mind gets
soft
why because I'm human I'm not some damn
you know hybrid creature that was formed
from the heavens above no not human I
suffer I don't like it I'm uncomfortable
I don't like it yeah so my mind starts
to get weak and we start to forget about
how badass we are I call that the cookie
jar but it's not about the cookie jar
right now yeah this is about self-talk
yeah but but the cookie jar kind of goes
to self-talk too yeah it's a piece of it
so basically what I do here is you have
to make sure that your mind doesn't
become [__]
when it's suffering when it's in pain
all it wants to do is find the easy way
out which is usually quick if you quit
the pain goes away immediately yeah
yeah you gotta give yourself enough
energy and fuel in your mind to stay
just a little bit longer so you can talk
yourself into stain for the whole thing
yeah that's how it works most of us
never start anything cold if you're
going to go to college you gotta steady
your ass off
if you want to run 100 mile race a
marathon if you want to go be Mr Olympia
if you want to go be a scientist a
doctor you're one of the best sales
people you've got to work you got to
work but this is
but what happens is in that moment we
need self-talk
when we're failing and we're in our
worst spot possible we forget
the back end yeah
oh my fault the front end the all the
build up to where we're at today
we forget how much work we put in so for
me I'm at my office one more time so so
I'm in the middle of it right I'm making
my calls I hate it you're at Mile 50. I
hate it your mind's getting you know
Wiggly on you I just want to get out of
here yeah we forget that we put years
yeah years maybe not into making these
dials but to get him where you're at
today to become this person to become
this person to be in a position to make
this money or whatever you want to make
whatever you want to do in your life
yeah
we forget that we forget that Journey on
what it took for us to get in this
moment to make the right decision yeah
so that's my self-talk is this okay I
won't get the [__] out of here man I'm
done
then I remember this
you ran 2 000 miles training to be in
this moment right now
we forget that we forget that three
o'clock in the morning runs or or
getting up early for work or whatever
you're doing we forget all that in that
moment of suffering I remind myself yeah
I only have 50 more miles I put in six
months of training you did 67 000 67 000
pools that's right Thirty right exactly
this is no big deal we forget all of
that yeah so what I do myself talk is
basically going back down memory lane
yeah all those days I ran the rain or I
had to study rule late at night and I
didn't want to do it but I did it to get
here yeah that's the hook that is the
hook that's the hook I want it to get
here yeah now you're here and now you
want to quit yeah so you gotta reminds
but just think about it if you haven't
put in any hard work
to reflect on
yeah
so there is no cell because you got
nothing to pull back it's just a lie
nothing to say hey you've done this
before that's right or you've done
something like this before all this all
this like people want to be all positive
all this positive talk it doesn't work
if it's a lot like
if you just study for your big exam
and you go into it saying I'm going to
pass it no you're not yeah you're gonna
fail it yeah that self-talk is not going
to work self-talk without real work is
just a lie yeah yeah so my self-talk is
me reminiscing back on the struggle to
get to this moment and that tells me
we're not quitting today yeah not today
yeah yeah and you say that when you're
living in Hell the only way to find your
way out is to confront the Devil Himself
you know who was that devil for you it
took several years for me to figure out
who the devil was
and the devil was my father
the devil was my father but what I
didn't put and never finished
was the devil really was me
so what happened was I put all this
blame and trust me my father and a lot
of people had to do with my upbringing
on how it was but like I put in that
book no one's gonna come back and say
hey man I apologize maybe someone does
very few people will
so at the end of the day when all things
are said and done with
while my dad was the devil and I
believed that for a long time I had to
confront him and I confronted the devil
so what I thought was the devil I
realized that I was the true devil
I was the one holding me back I was the
one looking for the escape goat and you
know I was the one looking for all these
ways to say it's okay David you're a
loser you're a born loser so it's okay
and I was hoping my dad was going to
give me that confirmation and he was a
loser himself but then the day when I
left there I realized man
it's on me my dad's [__] up my mom's
[__] up the people around me are
[__] up they're not gonna save you
you gotta save yourself my friend so
that's when all that reality hit me when
I went to Buffalo to see my dad another
drive home I was like man this rest of
your life is gonna suck
it is going to suck not because you're
going to be a loser but because you're
going to finally start to win
and winning is not easy my friend I was
300 pounds twice in my life
so every day I have my shoes laid out
because I hate running
people don't believe it I hate it
so that's what happens every day
I wake up out of my bed
and there's my shoes
my shirt my shorts
depending on the weather
there's some days I wake up
I just look at them for hours
and then I'll start walking around the
house
not sounding run today
I'm not doing it today
nothing I don't have to
that's what I think
I got 2.3 million followers on Instagram
you have an obligation not to yourself
but to everybody out there
that is touched by what you do as a
human being while nobody knows what I'm
doing
no one is videoing me
I am a virtual trainer mentally because
there's a lot of people out there saying
man David Goggins and after today
and if I wake up one morning and don't
do that
I go back to that David Goggins who lied
about being who we wanted to be
so my thing that keeps me going every
day
is my mission in life
wow I did not choose it
I'm an introvert and I hate what we're
doing even right now
if you always stay the course because
you know exactly what it is to not man
up
I've done that too many times in my life
so that's what keeps me going that's why
I talk about the warrior mentality and
that's why so many people are lost when
I start talking
you have
the right
you're lucky that you don't have to
think like Warriors think you're very
privileged I chose this world to be a
warrior now and I would choose it again
if I came back to this world
but the mentality of a warrior is very
different than normal mentality you must
be that person on that door oh get ready
to open it thinking to yourself
if I die
so be it
the only way you can go in that door is
knowing there's a great chance you're
going to die like being a seal you train
with live ammo you jump on an airplane
every everything you do
you could die
so to be a warrior why people don't
understand me I'm glad you don't
understand me Merry Christmas good on
you because being a warrior takes a
whole different mindset
a whole different mindset to know that
there's a great chance I may not be in
the middle like I was in for 21 years
I'm lucky
I'm very lucky that I'm alive able to
talk to you able to still run but when
you sign up on that line to be a set
like a seal your mentality changes I may
not live
you gotta accept that
and that's the mentality you have I
wanted to be an expert in the mind a
mental toughness guy Beyond mental
toughness the only way to do that in my
eyes is to put yourself in hell
put in Hell repeatedly
repeatedly put yourself in hell and
study how you process it
and that's how I was able to come up
with all these different ways all these
different tools to to slow the Mind down
inhale
because the mind just speeds up the Mind
wants to get out of the painful
situation the suffering it can't it
can't process it so that's what I
realized by going through all these
different processes of being in Hell
weeks you know it's just that how the
mind process is in hell were you ever
scared that you would lose the
processing ability to be able to coach
yourself through it well you have a
schedule I was uh there's some times
where the mind gets overwhelmed and you
cannot slow it down
but by these these certain tools I
developed by not allowing your mind to
get away from the moment
you cannot you have to think about the
exact moment that you're in but I saw
when I was younger
the moment became too big it became too
big I spazzed out and I would quit but
now I don't think about even like an
hour from now I'll be eating I don't
even go there
because in your mind yes no we must
Embrace this because now
there's you have to be a leader in this
moment it's not about you just getting
through it I had six God I had five guys
and six including me in my boat crew now
as the boat crew leader
so now another trick is this if you
don't think about yourself
there's no pain
which can also lead to pain later on in
your life but in these moments when
you're struggling if you are a true
leader and you're worried about your men
or women beside you
your mind is a care how cold you are
anymore
your mind's only worried about taking
care of the men and women beside you so
I started realizing man if I take care
of these cats to my left and my right in
the worst moments my mind is no longer
thinking about you're miserable David
Goggins get the hell out of here think
about how was John how was Andy how is
Sam how was Pete how hey how are you
guys doing you're not thinking about me
so there's so many things you can do to
get outside your own head to then allow
your body to be like hey we're just a
machine
but you have to let your mind be able to
process all these different tactics to
do that take a different vantage point
in life when you are in the hell
you can't see the beauty of being in it
when you're in it
get on top of that Mountaintop in your
mind
guess up that Mountaintop and look down
at what you're doing
you can see a whole different world that
world is beautiful but you got to get a
different vantage point in this in the
suck don't be in it spiritually get out
of it
get that soul look down on what you're
doing be amazed by the process of where
you're at now and where you came from
mediocrity is everywhere right now and
we're always trying to find an easy way
out and we're judging ourselves let's
say there's 10 people in this room and
we're all mediocre
but I'm the best
of the mediocre people
I now think I'm great
I'm great we surround ourselves around
people that make us feel great they tell
us what we want to hear the second we
put ourselves amongst the uncommon
people
we don't like that feeling that
challenge and feeling that of that
person's wake up at 3 30 in the morning
hey put your [__] on we're going for a
run we don't like that challenge we like
that person who says hey you know I mean
I don't feel good today man and they say
oh it's okay brother we'll take a day
off maybe get a pizza and watch the game
we like that we we love that feeling why
because you understand man we're good
bro we don't want that like this hey man
no bro get your [__] on man stop being a
punk we don't want dinner lives we don't
want that person who's constantly
challenging our weaknesses we want that
process constantly you know making us
feel nice and good and secure a nurse
that's the mediocrity of life we want to
be the best amongst the average people
people wonder how do you stay hungry all
the time
because after I accomplished something I
don't sit back like a lot of guys should
graduate buds you graduate this graduate
that they get comfortable they wonder
why I'm getting weak man I don't know I
lost my Edge what's going on because
once you hit the top of the mountain
guess what happened
I'm good
I'm good so you wonder why you're
falling down now because once you be top
of the mountain you gotta build another
one that's mediocrity there's a lot of
people in mediocrity who have a nice
resume
but they're one-timers man they hit they
hit a one-time deal they busted it open
got a lot of money but they're good
you're a mediocre now man what are you
doing today tomorrow the next day that's
why I'm listening to theorists
I don't listen all that [__] I
listen to them who's like this man
what's wrong man tired dude why are you
tired because tomorrow I gotta do the
again man whatever this is that made me
nauseous and sick to my stomach it made
me hurt
there's no ending
and that's the person I listen to that's
the person who's gained knowledge you
gain knowledge through suffering and on
the other end of suffering is a world
that very few very few have ever seen
it's a beautiful world because that's
where you find yourself
you don't find yourself in over here
you find yourself on the other end like
the 100 mile race all his arm I ran it
for 24 hours I found myself
on the other end of that race that 19
hours I found wow there's a whole nother
World out here that never even saw the
world's in your mind
and that's when all that mediocrity is
about mediocrity is contagious I'll
never forget when I was younger and I
lived in a seven dollar a month place
and everything was jacked up I had a
pair of jeans
and every I never forget this as long as
I live
you know first day of school people go
school shopping right good
week out two weeks out maybe a month out
we didn't have any money do that so this
pair of jeans that the inside of the
pocket was Green
the inside of the pocket was Green
now we're almost every day
so what I did for the next year of
school was I cut that pocket out so the
green would show so it looks like a new
pair of jeans
all I wanted was money
all I wanted was a nice car it was a
nice home
the second I got the money to do it
I realized
it's a bull
that's why I don't own a car I don't own
a place nothing what I realized is all I
wanted in my life
was look at that that accountability
mirror and be proud of
and everything else went away while you
need money to be successful you need
money to live you need money money does
buy a form of happiness because without
it you're miserable
but once I realized
it doesn't mean
it doesn't mean for me what makes you
happy
achievement
reaching goals
accomplishing things that I thought were
impossible to accomplish
because
well I don't smile all the time
there's this feeling inside of me that
no one very few people have
very few people have because when you
come from where I came from nothing and
you make something out of nothing
the feeling that stays with you all day
long it allows you to be who you want to
be in front of anybody
my mom didn't know how bad my grades
were she never saw one report card I hit
I hit everything from and she didn't
even asked she was so bogged down with
life and so I got away with a lot of
because her mind was occupied so it made
me honestly a weaker person so I scammed
life my mom helped me scam life for a
while but this time I couldn't scam life
I went the second time took the ASVAB
test failed it again
and a week later she got a letter in the
mail from my high school
and I'm a junior in high school and it
later says pretty much your son's gonna
flunk out he's missed 25 percent of
school because she was always gone
Sunday went to school he's gonna miss
school and so he's gonna flunk out so I
was exposed yeah my mom goes well she
read the letter to me she put my bed and
her best advice was guess what you're
gonna flunk out of school that was it in
the conversation so this is when I
developed my accountability mirror and
this is awesome I I look in the mirror
and at this time I didn't want to be the
black kid in school there's like five or
six of us in school and like 1700 kids
like that
and I made up a character
to kind of like draw attention from
color
okay and so what I did was I started to
design haircuts
and one haircut I had was the old man
and I shaved my head up here just like
this you did this I did this and I would
keep the hair on the side like old man
has
and one time I shaved my whole head and
had a reverse part so I had hair up here
they kind of zigzag so I did things to
be this cool crazy kind of like creative
kid you know like crisscross came out
this time this time I had pants sagging
but backwards so my so my back pockets
are here I had toothbrush I was crazy
man but I was a crazy cool kid in school
so I look in the mirror I see this
letter I'm I'm
[__] up
and I'm like you know what man no one is
coming to help me yeah I remember back
to my principal said because I went to
the principal when they wrote that in my
car and in my notebook
and the best advice he can give me God
help his soul was this
they're ignorant they spell [__] Niger
and so that's but honestly I talked to
the guy as I wrote my book
and I have nothing wrong with principal
Freeman
he he actually I actually interviewed
him for the book and he was happy
interview he was he's good man what the
[__] you could tell some black is your
white guy in White Society we could tell
me so I started talking to myself this
way in this mirror what's the best
principle because at that time like this
is the best you can do principal Freeman
that was my mind then but in in this
mirror it wasn't my mom it wasn't
principal Freeman it wasn't my dad it
was me
because when nobody coming back to help
David Goggins that was my mindset now
and so with my non-spelling ass I
started getting these sticky notes wrong
in writing you're [__] up and my mom
wakes up like what what is wrong with
you I go man I'm I have to change
because I I can't stay here I can't I I
looked at myself and I Was Defeated I go
look at myself I'm like who am I so I'm
defeating this mirror and I'm like okay
I'm changing on the other side of that
extreme place that I call suffering call
whatever you want there's a whole nother
world that people have not even examined
but you have to go to that extreme place
to examine it we want to stay here in
this comfortable place once you're going
to push yourself to that extreme place
it's like a whole nother Universe it's
almost like like you're an astronaut and
you've examined something like up in
outer space no it's always been there
but you have to be going through all the
muck and all the to examine it you
realize why God through all this crap
there's a whole other holy Universe over
here in my mind yeah on their Universe
we have a theorist we have a
practitioner
the theorist is a person that's going to
sit back and read books from a library
that somebody else wrote
they become real smart about what
someone else wrote okay
a practitioner is a man
is me I put myself in hell
lived in it for a long time and figured
out how the human mind works while being
while suffering while in pain while
misery and that's how I wrote my book
yeah I'm going to tell you exactly what
your mind is thinking most of us don't
stay in Hell long enough to write the
book yeah
I stayed in long enough to write it and
finish the book we all have a voice in
our head
some of us are very spiritual some of us
are not but we all have this voice and
you're doing this is wrong don't do that
the more you don't listen to that voice
the further that voice gets away from
your hands some people call it the Holy
Spirit some people call it God some
monks whatever whatever you call it it's
there we all have it
it's the right or wrong voice
but the more we don't listen to it the
more that voice goes away and only voice
you hear is yourself
we always when the only push hears
yourself you're wrong
there's a voice that guides you through
life and sometimes it's guiding you in
direction that you don't want to go
that's usually the right place to go
it's that uncomfortable place so that
voice is always talking to me but we
don't listen to it I listen to it and
when I start getting
anxious nervous like I've done we all
know we've done too much because it's
telling us I'm getting tired I'm wearing
down but we we go we go we go I start
talking to my fiance hey I'm doing too
much you start now like like I did in
hell week like I do all the time your
one second decision
it's that decision when your mind starts
to get so amped up whenever you can't
hear yourself think
you gotta slow down whenever you're
living off a schedule every day is a
schedule everything's a schedule you
have no time for yourself when you start
and we all know it I don't have time for
this anymore I have time for that
anymore that's when your mind and your
body are saying think about that I'm
neglecting my fiance I'm neglecting my
disciplines of life I'm neglecting my
reading my learning my my workouts my my
my diet you start neglecting all of that
foreign
you neglect one of them you can you can
neglect all of them a long time
it's gonna haunt you
when you start seeing that my God I
haven't eaten right in a long time
haven't been asleep by a long time it's
going to be one of those things to take
you off
so I'm I'm very aware
of my eating my sleeping my my my
disciplines of life you know I started
to get too far away from them
it's a hard stop
because what made me me
Other Self not just disciplines the
self-disciplines of life
those are always in front of you if you
have any they're always in front of you
so that's that's my heart stop what got
you up out of the chair honestly I
create this thing called the cookie jar
as I went through my suffering in life
to become who I was and the cookie jar
was every time I failed everything so
many times in my life and failure and I
would succeed I would fail and I would
succeed I had to figure out how to
succeed through failure and I put a
bunch of cookies in the cookie jar the
cookie jars are things when I start to
get the what was me mentality which we
all still get even though you know you
could be very successful I reach it and
I say oh this is my childhood and this
is what I did to overcome that because a
lot of times when you're in hell you
forget how great you really are because
at that moment you're suffering so you
don't you don't think about the great
things that you've done I take time to
really calm my brain down when it's
stressed out and remember where I came
from it's okay no we can do this we can
do this through a calm patient mind
figuring out how to do it so I figured
out how to do it how to get salt
electrolytes get some food get some
hydration back in me get my blood
pressure where I can stand up that was
the first mission I started with uh very
small goals you know it wasn't like I
went out there and well I started out
real big and I realized that the big
goals were just crushing me you know
because they weren't happening fast
enough
and I had to start making big things
very small and I had to take a lot of
Pride and a lot of uh self a lot of
satisfaction from the fact that you know
I had to lose 106 pounds in like less
than three months wow which was an
impossible task for anybody to do
so instead of looking at 106 pounds man
I was happy to lose a pound
I was happy to run a quarter a mile
because you know how it is as a power
lifter man you're not running anywhere
yeah
I mean for me when I was a power lifter
man I was so crazy about calorie content
and losing calories that I hate even
walking to the refrigerator you know I
didn't want to lose it I didn't lose any
calories because I knew losing calories
meant losing strength
so I was I was a freak of all that stuff
man so I had totally flipped my mindset
about all that stuff and just find very
small goals and started achieving them
being proud of myself through those
small goals that I accomplished what's
your purpose right now my purpose right
now is to continue
I used to have a wash rag and I did this
and you know how you take a shower you
have a wash rag in the cloth and you uh
you're sitting there and you're just
lathering up and before you hang your
rag up you want to get all the water to
come on it and you know get it all all
that you know all the suds out of it you
want to wring it out and you want to
hang it up
so my big thing is when I live my life
I want to make sure that when I'm dead
and gone that I ring that wash rag out
and that washback is my soul and I also
believe that we're going to end up one
day meeting the maker if you believe in
one
and I believe that maker knows
everything about you
everything about you no one else could
be here is talking to you knows
everything
but you also have a choice to make
you have a choice to make we have
choices and the one thing that scares me
to death in my life is getting to heaven
and not being what I'm supposed to be
and I believe that God has a chart and
he looks at the chart and he puts it in
front of you and get to heaven he says
hey that's what you're supposed to be
and one of my biggest fears in life
was to see that chart
and not have every block checked off you
know I want to make sure that I'm
constantly pursuing whatever it is I'm
pursuing just to be the best I can't
just constantly grinding myself into a
fine powder you know and but doing it in
a smart way like I talked about you can
constantly grind yourself into a point
where you're just sick
there's a there's a happy medium of
grinding so that's that's that's my
purpose now to continue to push myself
so others can see what is possible I
think we need to rethink how we frame
failure like I don't even like that word
you know what I mean because it implies
such a Negative outcome or perspective
like there should be a different word
for it and then we wouldn't be so caught
up in it you know what I mean what you
said is so true that word doesn't bother
me because I look at it like you are
trying to say it failure is this a word
for me failure was me
having more information on how to
succeed that's all failure became to me
so I failed so much pull-up records
running events had to quit this Buzz
Rangers all this crap had to go back
through all that was was oh I felt
because of these reasons here go back to
the drawing board figure out the right
equation put it together go back fail
again oh but I got more information so
everything I was afraid of I made sure
to meet it right in the face and
overcome it a lot of people are
listening to this right now and a lot of
people probably feel like crap about
themselves what is something that you're
able to share with people that can help
flip a switch or is there anything you
know or do they just need to come to
their own realization they need to hit
bottom they need to go through some
first in order to get there like what
are your thoughts on that
well you know what's funny man is that
I'm not speaking for every big guy by
any means but I was once the big man and
I and I realized a lot of the best big
guys man we got some serious demons you
know I hung around big guys and we are
we all you know we'd all break down and
we started talking about our personal
lives and how we all are and you know
hey why'd you become big man we all had
almost a similar story of
insecurities yeah and you know walking
around in the airport looking like a a
gargantuan man people look at you
differently and you get a little more
self-esteem so I'm gonna be talking to a
few of us out there when I say this man
the biggest thing in life that you have
to do
is you have to be proud of yourself
you have to start developing that
personal self-esteem
and it has to be something that it's an
internal thing
and it has to come from a lot of hard
work and dedication and you really have
to
I call it like like right now I see your
headphones on your head
I walk around life
with so-called headphones on my head man
I don't you know really wear them
obviously but I just have these ear
muffs on that I I silence out the noise
I silence out the Judgment I silence out
the self-doubt I silence out every all
the naysayers and you know those people
get in their head and then we start
getting her head and the most important
conversation we'll ever have is when we
have it ourselves and like you were
saying to yourself man I'm dumb I'm this
I'm not I was the same way so if that's
what you're constantly repeating to
yourself and that internal conversation
man that's who you're gonna be
and uh my my biggest thing for these
people who are out here is honestly man
you have to start callousing over that
victim's mentality
you have to start building this mental
armor
that no matter what anybody said that
you can be in a room full of a million
people
and all million can be like against you
and calling you names and whatever you
like this you know what Roger that you
can go for yourself man I know exactly
where I'm going I know exactly what I'm
doing and that's the kind of self-esteem
you have to build in yourself man in
this kind of society today because it's
it's tough it's tough out here nowadays
I started this crazy stress routine and
I literally have healed myself through
the discipline I had and what people
won't believe is I got to a point where
I stressed out for eight to twelve hours
a day so essentially like most of your
waking hours when you're not working out
stretching yeah and it went from that to
six hours a day then from six hours a
day to four hours and the more it opened
up so the hips and what you're saying is
there like a specific routine of
stretches that you would go through or I
would sit and stretch it's a whole big
routine a whole mess of like opening up
your abductors because your abducts are
attached to your hips your hip flexors
your everything is attached at this
region here your your midsection your
hips and my hips got so tight that I
couldn't even squat down I had so much
back pain so that's why another reason
why I started running running you stay
upright I couldn't squat anymore I
couldn't do any of that power lifting
stuff so I just only I can do is run run
didn't bother me too bad and it got the
point I couldn't run either and my
health got real poor then my spine was
collapsed and um I just got real sick
and basically I healed myself no doctor
can find out what's wrong so I couldn't
run a lot I couldn't do any activity so
I said you know I'm gonna bury myself in
stretching and what happened was I had
the shoes not on the back of my head the
knot came from my spine collapsing and
getting Tighter and Tighter and Tighter
it developed fluid or whatever long
story short as I started stretching out
that bump started going away and the
smaller the bump got the healthier I got
I was like what in the world is going on
so I would so I shave every day so I
would feel this bump in the bump and you
can see it right now yeah no I can see
it yeah most people think everybody's
bumping it back here my bump was like
this big it was huge and the more I
stretched the more it went away the more
it went away the more the healthier I
got I was like man so I'd be like I'm
Gonna Keep On stretching so my
stretching became it was crazy and I got
healthier and I was like my gosh I
stress more and more and more and now
it's I've been doing it now for three
years I haven't missed a dance
stretching in three years belief is
something it's not I can't tell you oh
believe in yourself that's a bunch of
crap
belief came for me
was going through those hell weeks
taping those legs up getting up early in
the morning by myself no coach getting
myself up
motivating myself every single day when
I'm out there in 240 mile runs and I
don't want to be out there and I'm 90
miles into it and I have 150 miles to go
and no one's there saying come on David
I'm forming belief
many people form belief in many
different ways for me this is how I do
it so when those Hard Times come my way
I know exactly how to get through them
when I first so I self-published my book
can't hurt me no one believed in me
I believed in myself
I sold them with five million copies of
that
now never finish this case it's coming
out December 6th
never finished I guarantee you the
audiobook will probably go now it's
probably one of the best audio books
it sounds cocky as hell of all time it's
truly amazing what we put into that book
because of how I've lived my life
a lot of people come up here and speak
about motivation and pushing yourself
and you're not doing it
they're not waking up every single day
they have a can speech they go off and
they tell you about
about what to do how to do it wake up
every morning make your bed take a cold
shower all that crap
I'm telling you right now
you have to be that person that leads
from the front many of you out here are
leadership positions
and many of our leaders right now are
not leading from the front they're
leading from the rear but they're
telling you
how to do it
they're waking up late
they're not doing what they say
so when life is real important to do
what you say because that's where true
knowledge comes from
and when I wasn't going through Navy
SEAL Traders one thing I told myself
I wanted to quit every single day
but many dreams die while suffering
and many of us out here have suffered
and when you're suffering I'm not
talking about just physically I'm
talking about emotionally spiritually it
could be a relationship when you're
suffering you give up on the very things
that you want it the most
when I was going through pear rescue I
wanted to be a prayer rescue man so bad
but that water haunted me
so when the suffering got too much my
dream died
and pretty much I almost died with it if
I didn't find Navy Seals and getting
past that hump and overcoming my demons
and facing my demons every day I would
have never been up here today
you cannot run your demons
they'll always know where you're hiding
trust me at that
and I'm in with this
don't stop when you're tired
stop when you're done my definition of
greatness is this
it's not a definition it's an example
this is greatness true greatness
let's say
that
I'm the greatest tennis player of all
time
okay let's say that I hate tennis
let's hear The Greatest Hits play of all
time
and I did 22 years I wrote all the grand
slams I have all the I beat Roger
Federer I am the best ever
and we're having an interview and you're
talking about my greatness what I
achieved and I'm retired
don't play tennis anymore haven't
touched a racket in years
and you're making me go back through my
life you're kissing my butt about how
great I am sure
and I'm answering your questions every
question I'm answering it I'm with you
but in the back of my mind all I'm
thinking about is all the times I could
have won those matches that I lost by
not bringing my best mindset you're
haunted
by all the opportunities that you missed
by not bringing your best at that time
when you could have won but you didn't
win because you allowed life
to interfere with that one shot when
you're sitting there getting ready to
serve for the match
and your mind is not thinking about
where that ball place needs to be but
think about
your family this or this at work or that
at work that's greatness
greatness is your recall on every single
shot that you missed throughout a
20-something year career every shot you
can go back and say I was here this
person was in the red shirt there
greatness is being so aware of the time
of life in the second that went by and
you can recall like it was yesterday
greatness is being able to go back there
not making that same mistake again and
being haunted by it
that is greatness I realized that God
wasn't going to give me a get out of
jail free card
and from the time I was born into the
time I was 19 years old
my wife had these hurdles I constantly
hit obstacles
obstacle after obstacle after obstacle
and I I had to figure out how to manage
suffering how like how to deal with it
because it's gonna be part of my life
forever at least that's what I thought
so in order to deal with it
I had to be able to conquer it and
overcome it and deal with it and know
that in this suffering there has to be
some kind of growth
with every obstacle I look at as
friction now without friction there is
no growth you have to have friction in
your life to grow
so I started looking at all these
different things versus the what was me
mentality like oh my God look at my life
my life's so I come from this family I'm
being beaten I'm being abused mentally
physically I started looking as a as the
perfect trial ground
try to flip it upside down it's okay I'm
suffering tremendously mentally
use this to your advantage versus your
disadvantage so that's what I did versus
looking at it as like oh my God what was
me I'm never gonna get out of here I
looked at it okay hang on a second hang
on a second
if I can overcome this if I can find
some power in this some way to get
through this
that right there will be the fuel for
the rest of my life and so I found great
strength and suffering
great strength in it because why through
all of that
it started to callous My Mind Over the
victim's mentality
this whole thing about suffering
yeah it sucks really bad uh really
really bad but we all live on this side
of suffering on this side this nice box
that's very comfortable that we know
when everything is going to happen we're
in it it's good we know how everything
is going to turn out
it's those few people who are willing to
go on the on this side of suffering and
once they get through that ask him how
he feels now
is bind how far he grew
in that short period of time
he grew so much more than a normal
person because he was willing to go
outside himself because on the other end
of suffering is greatness
it's not over here it's a whole bunch of
us we put ourselves in this great box
and then that box there's no suffering
in it so what we do is we is we sold to
ourselves from greatness
so for me for instance I was 300 damn
pounds
at one time in my life
spray for cockroaches made a thousand
dollars a month I was living in that box
I was sometimes look over the box and I
saw hell suffering storms Avalanches
tornadoes I'm gonna go over there but I
knew if I could get through that
mentally on the other side wasn't hurt
85 pound person was a Navy SEAL went
through Ranger school only person to do
this only person to do that only person
to do this but that's through all that
so you peek over the box and you go back
in and say oh I'm okay being 300 pounds
making a thousand dollars a month I'm
okay over here
and on the other side is where you start
to really start your journey
people think they start their Journey
because they're born
oh there's a lot of people in Graves who
a hundred years
and have never started their real
journey
your real journey starts when you go
outside that box
and you start climbing mountains and
start climbing mountains and you think
you're top of them out and you go down
their side of you think I'm here you
look at there's another I don't know and
it goes on and it goes on and it goes on
and just when you're getting ready to
quit
you crashed that final Mountain you get
down and you look
and there you are and it starts to make
sense to you then it doesn't make sense
to you until you get outside that box
I'll talk to so many people and what I
say is not for everybody so many people
don't have any clue on what the [__] I'm
saying because they're in this box and
it's their brain you first must go
through suffering to find that great
peace we're all looking for a lot of us
want to have there's a lot of books out
there about this five steps do this do
this do this get there no man it's not
that easy
find real permanent peace and
enlightenment
you must go to the dark side of Who You
Are
I could have easily this shoved my whole
life under a rug and went straight to
peace are you happy there you overcame
nothing
you just hell you skip tail for you you
forego this part of your life just skip
it and go right to peace
so you always have this thing back
because that's haunting you and that's
that Darkness
you must go into the darkness to truly
find that light that you're looking for
because that's what's on the other side
of that
people get it all wrong man you you have
to face suffering you have to face this
dark side this darkness and there's a
lot of energy in there
there's a lot of goodness in there
that you can use to find greatness but
you cannot find your peace you're
looking for in yourself
overcome yourself never
pick the easy Road
[Music]
um
never
never and it always goes back to kind of
the hero mentality never pick the easy
Road
ever in your life that is
the one road that is Doom
it is Doom
if you want something like six minute
abs all these different things if you're
wearing so fast you may achieve what you
wanted
but you want the permanent fix the
permanent fix comes from the Hard Road
the Hard Road gives you permanent
results
the easy Road gives you the Quick Fix
You will go back to where you started on
the easy route
that hard route is so permanent
that it ends up callousing you
everywhere
everywhere you keep a six-pack forever
because you know the work that goes into
it yeah it's funny that you're sitting
here saying that like things like public
speaking you find hard when you've done
all the crazy insane stuff that you've
done because I do them alone right I do
them alone yeah you know like I I pick
these hard things that most people think
you can't finish anyway
so you know you go out there you grind
you're alone you're in your own head I
work best alone right I work best alone
so those are easier you know I figure
out a way to kind of challenge you know
kind of challenge uh your mind Channel
it and challenge at the same time and I
figured out a way to kind of just become
have an indestructible toolbox in your
mind so those are easier I think that
when you die this is my own mindset that
you arrive in line
it helps me to get past a lot of things
you you arrive in line and let's say
you're in front let's say you died right
before me and you're in line and God's
sitting there with the clipboard okay
sitting every clipboard like me and
you're sitting right now he's looking at
you
and he says hey you made the heaven good
job okay
and then he shows you the clipboard of
what your life should have been
so you live this life that you thought
you pushed so hard then you look at the
clipboard let's say myself this is now
me I'm talking myself now and I say I
got to Heaven weighing 300 pounds
I was a a guy that worked for Ecolab was
the guy that kills cockroaches for a
living which is fine it's a job
but now look at this and that's how I
died I look at this and it says on here
where I should have been because God's
all-knowing right now look at this and
they said you should have been 185
pounds you should have broke against
book of world's record you should have
been a Navy City should have been that
should have been there you should live
this great life you should have been
inspiration you should have inspired
Millions
[Music]
and then you give the clipboard back to
God
they say you lived 80 years on Earth
and now you realize that you live here
being a shell of who you should have
been now you're in heaven
are you really in heaven
can now you see how much you've left
down there on Earth
the root cause of the quitter isn't that
you can't do 100 push-ups you can train
anybody to do that the root cause of the
quitter is when you get in hell you
can't process it
it's too much to process
because your mind starts going back to
the real reality of like I'm not ready
I'm not good enough
it's not trained
so I started training this
realizing that the only thing that makes
me quit is not the muscle fatigue it's
the mental fatigue that makes me quit
everything in life
so I became a practitioner of the Mind
the mind's a very powerful thing it has
a tactical advantage over you all the
time it knows your fears right it knows
your insecurities it knows where you
don't want to go so it will guide you
away from that
and that's why the mind will always win
until you reprogram it it will always
win until you reprogram it because the
mind controls you why is that it's your
mind
it's your mind because all those things
that happen to you in your life all
those bad things all those things that
you blame other people for they're now
yours to own you got to figure out a way
to reprogram your mind to get outside
the box there's always a a blockade
there's there's a barrier in your brain
there's a barrier
you got to find out what kind of removes
that barrier from your brain my biggest
barrier was my father
and once I removed that barrier I was
free to think
and once I felt good about myself I was
free to put action in
I never felt good about myself
I never felt good by myself whenever I
would get somewhere
the demon would come back put me right
back in the cage
if you don't go back like I'm a runner
left knee hurts a lot of people focus on
that left knee
a lot of times it's your right hip
and that's about life
you got to figure out what has messed
you up mentally go to the source go to
the source go to the origin of the
source
love peeling and onions strip it down
and that's what I did to myself
so that you know that whole
accountability mirror did you do it on
your own did you do it with any help
every single thing I've ever done that's
in that book or anywhere else was on my
own everything
if I can flip these insecurities upside
down if I can flip this fear if I can
flip all this that made me this
depressed insecure guy
if I can flip it and make it work for me
versus against me I started seeing the
power
the power and failure the power and
insecurity the power and self-doubt
because
I looked at everybody it may not be true
but that's how I looked at everybody's
being way above me I thought to myself
if I can be at the lowest part in the
world in the sewer
and be able to overcome all the I
started using that as power that I
slowly started passing the guys from
Harvard the guys from MIT the guys who
were these great from great families I'm
like oh my God I'm catching up I'm
catching up I had nothing so I started
flipping it and using this power I had a
starting point
and the starting point was this very
scared immature fragile kid
but through figuring out this fragile
kid
I found out
through all this [__] this can come out
the other end a person that was four
thousand Thirty pull-ups she runs miles
and miles and miles at a time but we all
have these abilities not just to run and
do pull-ups but these abilities that
once we go back into our dark holes that
a lot of us have a lot of us come from
you know insecurities a lot of issues
but we don't want to visit that place is
scary a place is something that we want
to forget about I had the courage
finally to go back in there and organize
it get it organized in my mind and
figure out you know where to start from
so but the journey led me to the
so-called superhuman stuff that I do now
for me my routine is every night I
stretch out and I stretch out for two or
three hours every single night without
fail yeah and while I'm stretching out
I'm thinking about my plan for the next
day
and I'm thinking about all these
different obstacles that may come up so
basically a lot of us aren't prepared
for life we get up willy-nilly in this
hope life is going to happen it is going
to happen but it's going to happen with
the prepared mind or unprepared mind
most people attack life with an
unprepared mind what I do is I try to
account for all things that could happen
might happen probably will happen and
then the unknowns
so basically I can't account for
everything but I do know there could be
some things that come up in life that
you need to be ready for I know for a
fact I'm not going to want to work out
tomorrow
therefore I'm preparing my mind for that
I don't want to do that I know tomorrow
will come with some difficult decisions
to make it may come with a getting a
phone call saying someone died this
happened that happened I'm always
preparing myself not in a morbid way
but just like look man be ready for life
don't let life just start attacking you
left and right make sure that you start
to build a mental armor
so then you're ready for life and that
comes with a very physical way and the
physical helps out to mental no matter
how far you get in life
you have to be able to go back to
scratching your mind
at a moment's notice
you can never get so far beyond scratch
what that means is
when you accomplish something in life if
you want to go back to scratch
and go back to that seven dollar a month
place where I once lived and visit that
place for a long period of time
if you were here when you went back to
scratch you would now be here scratch is
what makes you better
scratch friction obstacles create growth
there's no friction when you're this far
up in the game anymore
you think there is that's right when you
chase so much the friction is is minor
because why I'm sore I'm gonna get a
massage today mm-hmm
I'm hungry I'm gonna eat today the
refrigerator is always full so your
Comforts are now so your discomfort is
now very minuscule to your discomfort
back here in the seven dollar a month
place
so you have to go back to the total
discomfort to then raise your level of
where you're at now I'm not saying stay
there and stay there
visit visit it and then you raise your
level take a day trip that's right yeah
always take day trips yeah don't stay
there that's right but take a day trip a
day trip so I went down to the gym and
there's this like
crazy elliptical trainer but it's not a
normal elliptical trainer it's one that
you like almost self-power and it's very
it's not electric no yeah very difficult
yeah so I got on that thing and I
realized man this sucks and that's like
two minutes I'm like I don't want to do
this
so right then I realized hmm
it looks like we're gonna be here for a
while so I did that for two hours and 45
minutes wow yeah so
I'm not saying do that but that's
something I did today once my mind said
you know what let's not do this today
I said well since we're my my mind went
there I redirected it and said just for
having that weak thought
we're gonna be on here for a while right
so it does sort of sound like you're
punishing part of your mind in a way
punishment maybe not be the right word
yeah I want my mind to know who's in
charge
so for the better part of 26 years my
mind was in charge of me yeah which is
why I made all these horrible decisions
once you take control of your mind
you start making decisions for yourself
versus your mind making decisions for
you how do we learn from you in the
seals
handle our pain when we're in the midst
of pain
what because it hurts and it hurts
physically sometimes obviously and then
some of us are dealing with emotional
pain
what do we do in those moments when
we're feeling the most pain and we're
going I cannot
go one more second so this is the thing
a few years ago the Navy Seals designed
a program called
um the buds buds prep program in my last
two years in the military I did 21 years
they sent me down into Great Lakes
Chicago and we were training these guys
to get ready to go to butts still
training because a lot of guys weren't
getting through we thought this program
would help them get through
so these guys would leave our program
studs push-ups sit-ups swimming
everything
but the numbers were the exact same
so I was scratching my head like how the
work these guys go through two months of
this before you get the buzzing still
quit I started going back through my
mind and realizing one thing we were
building bigger stronger faster quitters
why is that
if you don't work on the one thing the
most powerful weapon in the world is
your mind yeah
so to answer your question is this
whether it be physical pain or mental
pain
we all have to start from zero with pain
and what that means is if you don't go
back we all have something that bothers
us everybody in this world is insecure
about something that's right something
in life whether it be your family your
mom your dad your brother your sister
your wife your husband your kids
something has messed you up
and whenever you're in physical pain
even though you might not be thinking
about that
mental stuff that happened to you
your mind is thinking about it all these
dungeons that we've created all these
trap doors that our life has created
most of the time we quit is because we
don't have any mental tools to get us
through the other side so my whole thing
for people is you have to examine
why are you doing it in the first place
what makes people quit so much in still
training in all other special off
training is the mind it's always
comfortable to sit there you watch the
Navy SEAL show Discovery Channel you're
in a 72 Degree house you have your
lemonade your milkshake whatever yeah I
can do that oh sure you're comfortable
although I'll say this I never say that
well some people do yeah a lot of folks
think you know because it feels very
comfortable in that comfortable
environment oh I totally absolutely the
second you get out there in that
environment where it's 40 degrees like
in my third house we you know we had a
guy die of pulmonary edema died out
there in my third hell week
you have to really want what able you
know whatever you're going for yeah if
not all these questions that come up
like I said hi how you go one more step
further yeah your mind is going to ask
you all these questions
hockey go one more step further if you
don't have the answers to that and I
can't give them to you yeah that's right
you have to know why am I here for me
when I was going through still training
I was willing to die so all these
negative questions that kept on coming
up my head I had the answer for him it's
those people that don't have the answer
for those negative questions right and
if you can't answer those questions you
will quit right would you say you've
built this almost like sadistic quality
where you almost enjoy the pain
I don't enjoy it
it's necessary yeah
necessary so every morning I wake up
it's not just about working out but for
me working out has been a very big part
of my mental growth
so for me if I am not challenging myself
every day and I swear to God people will
not believe it I was over almost 300
pounds twice in my life
a person that does that twice in his
life does not enjoy cardiovascular
activity okay yeah so people can put
anything they want to in their head I
did realize one thing
the things I don't enjoy that I still do
that's where growth is at
and that's for me the only place growth
is at is in that very uncomfortable you
know in that uncomfortable Zone yeah so
I have to visit it every single day when
you're mine this is this this whole 40
rule that I talk about all the time
that I made up a long time ago and I
started making it up through pain tell
me what that is what'd you go so
basically the 40 rule is I am a strong
believer that we quit because why how
the 297 pound cockroach guy right who
quit on everything is now considered
when the bass man has a planet how is
that possible it means I had to change
one thing my mindset
so there's no way in hell that that was
in but that was that guy was in me
one that God came down here and said hey
guess what man you're a fat ass but I'm
gonna now make you a badass I want to
miracle
to be a badass no it was in me
I had to believe and make that belief
work and through hard work I did that so
the 40 rule was like we have a like a
car some cars have a governor on it and
when you get to like 92 miles an hour
that car start doing this because you
can't go any faster
those cars that don't have Governors on
like like a fast ass whatever Porsche
whatever I'm gonna bury it gone
we have that abilityness but we have put
this governor on our minds
and you have to the factory that put the
governor on that car the factory is now
you
that put this show in your mind you
gotta take that off
until you take it off you're gonna
constantly get to 92 miles an hour and
do this yeah because you need to grow
faster
in fact you might even go slower
so basically I started realizing this
through my life through going through
all these times it's more important to
own your weaknesses
you have to really triple down on those
man because why you want to become a
full human being we like to run away
from weaknesses like for instance if
you're good at running all you want to
do is run if you're great at reading you
have several books but we don't do those
things that we're not good at so for me
I realized I keep on running away from
these things I'm not good at I have to
dive into these things I had to become
one with these things and that's what
happened and so I I own them both yeah
and I talk very openly about them both
do you think there's I don't know
balance is the right word but do you
think there's there is a point in time
where you can sit back and say let me
take this in a little bit
I for a long time was probably the most
unbalanced on the planet Earth and I
take I took great pride in that yeah I
it was all it was on purpose it was on
purpose because I knew for me to get to
where I wanted to go where I had to go
there could be no balance there there
could be no well eight hours a day I do
this and then yeah no nine to five no no
it had to be I'm such a spot in my life
I'm just in a dark place that if I don't
dedicate 24 hours a day seven days a
week 365 a year to becoming a better
human being it's not going to happen
yeah and so the people who were in my
family had to realize hey I'm sorry that
you may think I'm neglecting you right
now but if I don't fix myself
I won't be good for anybody so yeah I
became very unbalanced for a long time
I'd be balanced is important
but you have to first go to war with
yourself you got to figure out what
you're about and be proud of who you are
before you start to get that
teeter-totter nice and balanced out so
yeah that makes sense I think I think if
I'm hearing you right what I what I hear
is that in order to create maybe some of
that balance down the road you have to
get a foundation under you that's right
right if you don't have that
foundational knowledge of who you are
and how you show up and what you're
capable of yeah it's pretty hard to walk
in any sort of balance between work and
career and family and all the other
things that you have going on that's
right so if you read my book and you see
what goes on you'll see how many
mistakes I make along the way trying to
find balance trying to find peace in
myself and I keep myself all up I'm
having relationships I'm having you know
I I get a girl you know knocked up she's
pregnant now I'm I'm in the worst spot
in my life
you know I don't have a real job I'm
going through seal trading I haven't
graduated still training I'm going back
and still trading for the third time and
now I have a girl that's pregnant I I'm
all over it's gonna have you know I have
no money I have I have nothing and I'm
establishing a life with the family and
I'm all [__] up so you know a lot of
us get in situations where we start
establishing all these different things
and pop up all these different pop-up
boxes in our life is
okay we haven't fixed ourselves you know
until you fix yourself
don't don't start another Journey before
you finish your own Journey first or not
finish it at least get a good you know
foot start into it so I'm the only
person in the history of Navy so trained
to go through three hell weeks in one
year can you explain a little bit what
hell week is because I I heard it on
your audiobook a lot yes and it just
sounds like a painful moment that very
few people are able to handle it it is a
very long painful moment so
I don't know what week it is but for me
it was my third week and sometimes it's
your third fourth or fifth week in Navy
SEAL training the Navy still training
six months long
and this is like the biggest Crucible in
Navy so it probably in all the Special
Forces you know Special Ops
it's 130 hours
of continuous training
and you might get two hours of sleep
and the whole idea is you start on
Sunday
and you end on Friday you might get two
hours of sleep and the whole idea of
this train is to get a man
and break him down to nothing
and that's where you see what a man is
made of
so to make it through one most people
say I'm never going back through again
so I was forced that God blessed me so I
started looking at at these failures as
blessings
because with all with all these failures
and all these bullies and all these
being abused and all and my learning
disabilities and stuttering and
everything I had in my life
they are really gifts yeah and it's not
some psychological Babble that I'm using
to say oh no my life wasn't that bad no
my life sucked
but they truly were gifts because all
these different trials and tribulations
LED my mind to where it's at now
so um hell week once again 130 hours you
get two hours of sleep maybe and they
beating like push-ups sit-ups in this um
near the Pacific Ocean so you're out in
the Pacific Ocean back in and that
water's freezing
and so you see these men these great men
that I watched on TV I'm now with them
and for the longest time I put people
who had better childhoods better grades
better this better that I put them all
above me
but now I'm on the same playing field as
them so when you get on the same playing
field as these men who you think are
better than you you look at them eye to
eye and you realize that they're not
so once again I'm starting to do all
this live autopsy like saying God man
you remind yourself your whole life
thinking that this person came from a
nicer house better education better mom
better dad and they're better than you
it's not the case
you have this in you you may have to dig
a Little Deeper to find it you know
their their family may have
started them off a lot better than you
but it's there yeah it's there so I
started really realizing how powerful
the mind was in that third hell week for
several years I gave myself a way out
when you were three no 300 pounds and I
was only up until I was 24 years old
I would climb a mountain I'd fall back
down I started climbing I fall back down
for the first 24 years of my life
I went to my first tail week my second
hell week and then my third whole week
came and still training and the CEO
Captain Bowen looked at me I'm on
crutches I'm all jacked up he says hey
this is your last time you're gonna go
through buds
zit
I had several stress fractures
I had double in them on you I was jacked
up and he gave me a few months to heal
they said this is your last time going
through I shouldn't even let you go back
through wow I started me to be still
training with stress fractures
stress fractures
and this is when I started to not put a
cap on the on the body if the mind is
there every morning I wake up at 3 30 in
the morning four o'clock in the morning
go to my dive cage
go in there before anybody saw me I get
duct tape and I would tape from my
forefoot all the way up to the middle of
my calf and I would put two black socks
on and so I ran not using the pivot oh
my gosh and I ran my hip flexors so for
the first 45 minutes to an hour I was in
absolute excruciating pain
but what motivated me
I do that whole process
was a fact that
this kid
came from that
I'm in the hardest train in the world
in the worst shape of my entire life
what if I can graduate amongst these
studs wow
all these guys around me are studs
they're stallions they're Gladiators in
my class they're all healthy most of
them they're not broken like this they
may have some you know everybody's sick
going through that training but if I
graduate
it would change everything for me if I
can start the hardest chain in the world
broken
and graduating so my mind fed off of
that
you are now from the weakest man you're
now the hardest man to ever live if you
can do this if you can do this
life is one big mind game
and you're playing it with yourself is
it true I don't care
it got me through the hardest training
starting out broken where most people
quit
I had just started wow and when you take
that mindset and you learn to flip that
around
that's what made me powerful
and my body followed and three months
later
my stress fractures were healed by
running on them do you like suffering or
do you just deal with suffering real
answer real answer yeah
real answer I like to get a bunch of men
together okay men that are the hardest
of the hard
and I want to be with these men
and I want to see them suffer
because I'm suffering right along with
you but I want to see me get through it
I want to see What You're Made Of I want
to see like almost like the Coliseum
in Rome let's go to the Coliseum
and the only way to see who the baddest
there is is to suffer you can't do it by
writing a paper so let's go
because why what I found out through my
life was I thought of myself as some
weak little kid
if I found out and the only message I
want to get across to people
is once you change one thing your
mindset
you can attack everything and I find it
fascinating I'm fascinated
because I'll be in these moments I put
these guys on some pedestal yeah which
people do with you they do with me and
they shouldn't
and I was this guy who was a piece oh my
God how are you guys it's amazing but
once I worked my way up there
I said my God man we can all compete
let's go so do I like suffering I like
suffering in the way that is
competitive
that brings out the absolute best in me
and in everybody else
so like I want to see a man be defeated
I want to see a man get broken
it's
I love these men these men I love but
there's very few of them there's very
few of them and there's very few that
are willing to go there
more than once is there any part of what
you do in your day
that actually just really enjoy it's not
overcoming demons or overcoming voices
you just actually think this just
actually makes me happy and I really
like it what's funny about it sitting
over there oh yeah well my fiance is one
of them but honestly what's funny about
this is people may hear all this and say
God this guy's such a structured guy
talking about demons getting over things
that's not like his whole life
it's true
but I'm the most peaceful person on the
planet Earth even with like the
conversation like I go to the gym I have
to do this have to do that
every day I'm winning
every day I'm winning the uh the other
voice in my head so I'm I'm very I'm I'm
at peace of myself
the things I do for fun are like me
bettering myself yeah I love sports I
love watching sports but also love
accomplishing and overcoming myself
every day because every day is a battle
every day is a battle because your mind
wants to choose the path of least
resistance every day
but you don't become better by by ever
doing that you become normal and I don't
want to be normal so it may not be a
life for everybody but I find a lot of
Peace in not being normal in my life so
I'm going to show you something I
haven't shown anybody before Oh no I
don't know I don't know no I'm not going
to show you no no so you see these
little spots right here in my body yeah
yeah see this yep so basically
these everybody wonders
what happened right
these are very small spots I look like a
leopard all over they were all over my
body really so just to give you some
insight
so
I've talked about on several podcasts
but I haven't shown anybody like my my
leopard skin and what happened so I
could take off my I can show you all
kind of nastiness man I'm not gonna do
that I can show you my ears and I'll
show you one thing right now this part
right here you see this little dry spot
on my ear oh yeah yeah and if I were to
dig in my ear right now nothing but it
would come out really a whole bunch of
crust I'm taking you there why this is a
man show that's right that's right we're
gonna go with it let's go there okay
we're gonna go there so I don't talk
about it on most shows but what happened
was over a period of time of me
literally trying to transform myself and
a guy asked me a question yesterday man
um am I paying now physically for what I
put myself in I said yeah I am but we
just understand was I you know I was 297
pounds and I was a piece I wasn't going
anywhere in life
I asked myself that question before I
decided to put myself through hell are
you willing to do it or am I willing to
pay the price am I willing to do it and
I willing to pay the price after I
myself up because I knew for me to get
to where I wanted to go I didn't have
the ability the ability was not there so
I knew I was going to break myself off
to do it some people are born with this
great talent I wasn't smart I I wasn't
some physical specimen I wasn't in that
stuff so I knew for me to go through all
of
the end of it was going to be a broken
broken man
so I did it and in the process of doing
it I knew all along the way
one day and that time came
that time came in in that book
that Soul has muscle I'm talking about
right literally for me being in that
fight or flight mode and pushing and
pushing Way Beyond what I thought was
even possible I kept on finding new and
new and new limits as I was going on
this journey so but in doing that you're
breaking your body down tremendously
sure yeah so what happened to me was
my that so has muscle test your lower
body upper body mine became so tight
that it literally left probably I would
say baseball size lumps on my hip and
those so these are my muscles that just
tightened up and tightened up up to my
hip flexion and it was just Contracting
right there just Contracting right here
so I thought I had two two lumps like
this we're right here and no one knew
they were and on the back of my head I
had a big lump on it and you can kind of
see it now oh right yeah I can't it used
to be an extra inch and a half really so
this is where my sickness was coming
from so a doctors give me all kind of
medication and I kept on getting worse
and worse and worse because you were
going through the same type of training
at this point or were you hung up at
this point so at this time I'd already
done like 19 years in the military yeah
I've done all these Ultra races and all
sorts so I've I had gone through the
gamut but no one knew that every time I
got to start line of an ultra race
I was broken at the start line so I
didn't go as Ultras like oh I'm healthy
I'm ready to go I'm all feeling awesome
I went to start my Every Damn Race I
ever did broke it a lot of times I went
to storm I was stress fractures
compression tape on if you look at me
and that bad water tape in my first bad
water you can see at the end at the end
of bad water there's a video before I
get interviewed and they're taking off
the compression tape I had that start
line damn wrecks you started so my
mentality was was geranimalistic it was
it was something that that it was it was
Barbarian type of like a mentality
so but that cost me it cost me a lot but
um and that's what happened to my body
my my body slowly started to uh
literally choke itself out so I lost two
inches of my height
due to that so as much let's test your
T12 just gripping down so what you see
here all these little leopard spots on
my body
is basically as I started opening my
body back up it infection
started coming out everywhere so I got
to the point and I hit it from the still
teams for a long time the last two years
is the Navy SEAL I couldn't buy Salva
which is clear in your ears to go
underwater yeah that yeah that depth was
probably tough but luckily we drive you
know we we were diving dragger systems
so you're gonna go like like 15 20 feet
but it's still at 15 20 feet you still
got to equalize you know and get your
you know about Salva so I was literally
just busting my eardrums out to go down
because all that ear wax that's now
coming up I got so tight my traps and
everything shut off my eustachian tubes
so whenever the doctors would go they go
hey Doc I cannot clear my ears they
would go in and check my eardrum and
they'd be like you have the cleanest
ears I've ever seen in my life you don't
have any earwax why
I was trapped and cut off so the second
I opened all this stuff and my fiance
will tell you it's gross
it just comes out like for two and a
half years because it's been backed up
but then it's just it's a it's a sick
it's and then the the leprous sponsor I
opened something up in infection it's
it's it's it's something that I can
write a whole book about but now after
five years of doing this
I am uh in the best shape of my entire
life because my body even going into
still training because my my childhood
was so messed up yeah and that sore as
much starts to get tight then
that eyewitness still training really
out of shape or as far as my health sure
and I just I would tape it up my
mentality was taping up man I I just
taped it up and kept on going in it and
I paid the man but it was worth it life
beat me up
bad I mean I was uh knocked out and uh
12th round of a 15 round you know
heavyweight bout I was knocked out
but what happened was in the 12th round
when the Challenger turned his back on
me I was getting
and I got up and won the next three
rounds and knocked that [__] got
in the 15th round so that's my mind
about Ken hurt me I was hurt man like
you literally I had to overcome so much
those first 26 years of my life and I
still do every day today you know it's
not over but the mentality of can't hurt
me is just that no matter what's in
front of you man you have to face
you have to confront you have to
overcome and move forward so my father
you know some of the kids that bullied
me my learning disabilities all these
things I went through in life stuttering
you know has so many different issues
failing and failing and failing at over
come on
or they would overcame me what moment in
life was it when you just said like with
this did you work on all your all your
weaknesses and you changed yourself
right because I saw the picture before
it was fast before yeah right and and
now now you look so healthy so fit you
look like like a perfect human being
this is well what happened was so I
graduated high school I finally
graduated I finally passed the military
interest exam the ASVAB
I wanted to be an Air Force Pet Rescue
man and I won't get deep into that but I
failed miserably at that so I went from
175 pounds out of high school to
297 pounds within the four year period
so basically I'm about 22 years old now
maybe yeah about 22 years old I'm 297
pounds I'm out of the Air Force
and my job is I'm spraying for
cockroaches at a company called Ecolab
so I'm making a thousand dollars a month
and my job is from 11 o'clock at night
at 10 o'clock in the morning to go
around and spray for cockroaches
so every night for six months I'm doing
this job so I finally get home one night
and well trust me it wasn't like
overnight this happened you're haunted
by the mere fact that you're a piece
yeah every day and people don't think
that you are lying
so every day of my life I'm haunted by
my father the kids that bully me my own
insecurities all these things are just
this this Roost in the back of my head
so I'd be driving home at like seven
o'clock in the morning from all night
shift
and all alone in my truck and I'll be
thinking my life is hell
so one day I came home
and I always come on watch TV
and the show was on with like Navy Seals
yeah and um I'm afraid of water I sink
like a rock so I'm sitting there
watching these guys going through Navy
SEAL training
and I'm like
and I saw with
I believe how you know how a man should
feel very you know have pride and
dignity himself yeah it's like I gotta
change myself
so literally I sat down in the castle
watching these guys going through SEAL
training
and I went through my own mental
checklist
of how [__] up I am and how many
things I would have to change just to
get an opportunity
to try out for something like that have
to get smarter have to get fit have to
lose weight have to do all these things
start running swim and everything
so I finally get to a point where um I
get the courage to go to a recruiter and
say Hey I want to go try to do this but
when you tour 97 pounds and you're gonna
go try to be one of the fittest people
in the world yeah you get laughed at
so I got laughed at a lot but in this
process this process was actually
hardening my mind
all the laughter because the laughter
used to make me cower now I realized I
can no longer hide from my insecurities
high from all these fears I just start
wearing them yeah had to start talking
about them had to start being vulnerable
because I was always afraid of them
so here I am now I'm facing them I
finally find a recruiter that says hey
we'll take you in and he says you have
less than three months to lose 106
pounds
I'm like that's possible
so that was my mindset I was like hey I
can't have that kind of mindset so I
went to the dungeon and started using
all my insecurities and strength
instead of looking at being bullied and
uh my dad messing me up and all that
stuff like that I looked at it as
who could have survived all this
and still be here with the opportunity
to go to Navy SEAL training
and so I started using all these
negative things and started flipping
everything on top of his head instead of
saying what was me kicking rocks head
down in the dirt I started saying it's
not a
planet
who would have this opportunity coming
from where I came from they would be a
statistic yeah so I started looking at
it as power versus like big time defeat
those scars are real
those scars are proof that you know your
path is real so they're never going to
go away I I own them but I'm I'm proud
of my childhood
I'm proud because without all of these
lessons in life and everybody says this
I mean it I mean it because I was able
to look at my childhood how I grew up as
the ultimate training ground for my life
someone there have to be some people in
this on this planet Earth who have my
mentality
as gross as it is to some people and as
far off as it is and not understood
there has to be some people like me on
this planet Earth
has to be some Warriors out there that
are able to take this mindset and do
something with it so that right there
once you are able to look at your life
and realize that all these bad things
are actually the ultimate training
ground for what you're going to and you
know encounter in life
you start looking at your past very
differently I started to create the real
Rocky I wanted to be the the real
version of a movie
and but that's the hard part though that
movie's inspirational
and in my life there's a lot of times in
my life it wasn't so inspirational
there's a lot of lonely moments where
there was no Going the Distance song in
the background to keep me going yeah the
music changes things doesn't it yeah or
lack thereof or they're lack thereof man
there's a lot of times a lot of quiet
times a lot of failure a lot of
disappointments a lot of starting from
scratch but that's when I started to
develop a different mentality and I
started to develop a mentality of this
is where it's at
where you find out where you're at is
when you're at the lowest part of your
life so I started to develop a whole new
mindset like the lowest part of my life
used to make me feel bad
the lowest part of my life now it
actually gives me strength because I
know so many people stop that's where
they quit right when they get to the
Sewer of life versus looking at it
saying oh yeah now let's see let's see
the millions of men out here in this
world they're not going where I'm
willing to go now this is where people
stop
and this is where I started to develop
the different mentalities you want to
test my resolve you want to test my
ability to go the distance you want to
see where your life is and mine begins
to answer that mentality started for me
because I started saying man you always
end up in the dungeon
you gotta find strength in that where no
one else does
so that that Rocky movie was a little
bit of a spark
but to become that person it takes a lot
I was this nobody guy
and I created this Goggins and that
Goggins there's David Goggins and
there's Goggins David Goggins is a calm
cool guy that sits back used to be uh
you know weak kid now he's just a normal
guy Goggins is a guy that is willing to
tape up his legs to go after it
um in that book you read about David
Goggins and also Goggins
what I realized in my life is that
Goggins is who I love
Goggins is who I created my dad created
David Goggins
I created Goggins so what's happening
with me and since can't hurt me came out
and since I got on social media which is
why I don't like social media which way
I'm not on there very much which I give
people one time
I have to do me
I have to do me so people get it twisted
man I am who I am yeah what's in that
book is me yeah yeah so now what they
see is this guy who's trying to get
people to get off their ass that just
happened to happen man I didn't set out
when I set out to be a CEO and set out
to go to Ranger school and all this I
did and break records I didn't set out
to please
right I didn't start to say hey pay me
now I got a great story and I realize
now that my life has kind of gotten to a
point where people know me I have
followers and whatnot the biggest
depression of my life
is you get caught up into helping so
many people out and it's great and I
love that but you lose yourself in all
of that truth it literally and people go
man but but my God like you're you're
changing I get all that man but what is
motivating you in that book
what's motivating you is the stories I'm
telling you about what I did in my life
once I stopped living that I'm no more
yes I am not that you are now being
motivated from
so right now in the mirror I now got
back to Goggins
I'm now back to running 100 miles a week
I'm not back to getting I saw and I
talked to my girl about all the time
you you you travel you speak you you
know you you all it's all great and
dandy first up for most people
I'm Goggins what makes me me is the
dungeon and yeah and people well oh my
God like they're gonna here's my god
dude you don't have any peace and you're
like don't get it twisted weak people
who hear me get off poopy pants about
how I talk
so be it
what changed me was I had to be hard on
myself yep and I have to continue to
grind myself into a fine dust yeah
period that's where I feel good I
accomplished something if things come
easy it's not fun I must fail at
something repeatedly it has to haunt me
and then once I complete it I feel like
I accomplished something I don't want to
sit out and say oh
there's an a we're good no I don't turn
in a million times and say you fail you
fail that's okay Roger that and sit
there and analyze what I'm doing wrong
go to these places that people don't go
to anymore because all this social media
everything's computerized I want to go
to that dark place in my mind and say
okay how are we gonna get this done
honestly it was um I realized at a young
age how to change myself was through
discipline and the military didn't teach
me that it was something I realized I
had zero discipline zero self-discipline
and I realized I have to start
developing this and I started really
because I was horrible at reading and I
was horrible at writing I have so many
learning disabilities not even funny so
I just sit down at the table and spend
so much time
in this reading and writing and learning
and that kind of translated over to my
self-discipline with working out so
that's where it started I started when I
was about 16 years old and said well I'm
a fourth grade reading level
you know let me go ahead now and start
really uh focusing because I'm not gonna
get in the military because I gotta pass
the test yeah so that's where it started
for me I have zero anger
I'm a passionate guy so I but I get it
though sure the way I talked I come
across I'm an aggressive guy
because that's what it takes to like if
you walk into a situation into a fight
I'm not saying be so aggressive that
you're that you're so aggressive that
that you're making bad moves short but
if you don't have a little flame burned
in you knowing that I might get hit real
hard and when I get hit I have to attack
I have to I have to I have to bring I
can't get knocked out right right you
have to have that mentality of when I
went to hell week
I knew I would get broken
I had to have an internal flame in me
that can never be it couldn't be kindly
Kinley you put the water in the kidneys
out right y'all I had to be a tree that
is burning hard it's burning for a long
time and that's what I became man so
it's not angry anger can't sustain you
for a long period of time because once
you get in a situation try trust me I
tried it before when you get in a real
hard situation
and you're miserable
miserable
that anger is gone what comes up is real
the real feeling of who you are and
where you're at you don't want to care
about the people who made funny in high
school or your dad beating somebody
because now you're you become selfish
you're like let's say you're in hell
with you that cold water was 50 degrees
and you're and your balls in your mouth
right now you're thinking oh dude like
your minds are thinking those kids in
high school bullied me or my dad's at
least your worries no you're thinking
so let anger can feed you for so long
there has to be something so deep in you
that drives you so what what really does
it for me
is I know what we're capable of
and I know that most human beings
aren't willing to go where I am
and that's a very very dangerous thing
I'm not saying I'm bearing anybody else
that everybody has this Talent sure it's
not a talent it's just realizing that we
stopped way short of our true potential
you know right now until I'm dead I'm
still examining human potential how far
can the mind go how far can we go as
human beings so that's you know I'm the
I call myself the Stephen Hawkins of of
the mind you know he was obsessed with
everything he he ever dove into
you know the guy couldn't walk or
anything you know so he was like the
mind that's one thing he didn't want to
lose and I became obsessed with it
because it's the one thing that
controlled me
so I became obsessed with this what is
this thing up here that just has me on a
on a tightrope and just walks me into
all these horrible decisions I'm making
makes me feel so pathetic and weak and
insignificant and dumb and stupid and
everything I gotta get control of this
thing but it's amazing that once you get
control of that thing how far you can go
when I retired I retired from the
military for about fifty thousand
dollars a year is what I probably make
for me for a guy that grew up with
nothing I lived in a seven dollar a
month Place growing up for a long period
of time and then we moved to a 236
dollar a month place
so basically
you give me fifty thousand dollars I'm
rich yeah so
my mindset was about helping people and
when people truly believe in your
message and believe in who you are and
they see that you're being honest and
truly honest for the fact that hey I
just want to see you be better I don't
want nothing maybe a thank you when
you're older and you're walking around
with your kids and your family
if you have a real authentic true
message about people and people see that
you're not trying to sell out and and
not trying to sell them things because I
knew how I felt growing up
and I don't want anybody to feel that
way
so when I give back it's not about
giving back to like say oh well
hopefully down the line I can sell them
something yeah my message is truly
authentic to how I came up and people
feel that therefore the business is
about them yeah and I got I have all
these Lessons Learned through a life
that God blessed me with as far as I
look I didn't survive this life I
thrived in hell yeah and through that I
was like a guy sitting back I was like
just writing all this down I became a
poet in hell just sitting there as hell
was all around me I was all calm it's
taking it all in oh I gotta I gotta tell
people This I Gotta tell people that oh
I learned this I learned that while most
people run from it I was learning from
it and now I'm just giving all this
knowledge to people for free yeah
so in return people are growing people
like the message and uh when you have a
good message you grow a business what
gives me food is I know that most people
who are blessed with so much talent
great parents great upbringing didn't
come where I come from
they're gonna quit before me
having all the tools that they have they
didn't have the ability to examine
themselves
when you have everything so nice in life
it's great to have a great life yeah no
doubt but what happens is you don't
self-examine
you don't do a live autopsy when you
have a life
it almost forces you to do a live
autopsy it forces you to find strength
from places that no one looks from
because food is not at the ready you
know you're me I have a learned
disability it's not at the ready I can't
just pick up a book and start reading
right right there's preparation we had
everything I do
there's there's everything I do has to
come with so much preparation it's
despicable it makes me sick my own
personal life makes me sick that's why
I'm so disciplined now without my
self-discipline there is no David
guidance
like I can't like stop reading I won't
be able to read tomorrow
it will I will lose it that fast wow
yeah you know I you know I cannot stop
going to the gym
my mind is set up in a spot where hey
the second I stop it wants to stop
because I had a quitting mind growing up
when you get beat at you all the time
your mind wants to go to that nice spot
where you're comforting we're not trying
we're just easy that's where your mind
it doesn't want to think you have all
these things in the mind and the mind
can only absorb so much
so all the pain it has to go through it
doesn't it wants to push it away it says
let's not do that
so every day I'm fighting where the Mind
wants to go so it's a it's a it's a
constant it's a constant Evolution man
I'm I've never arrived
I've never I'm kind of that's right now
I'm stressing out two three hours every
I'm trying to reinvent the wheel I'm
like oh man I went through Navy SEAL
training being [__] up
I ran over 7 000 miles in 2007 being
[__] up I did pull-up records being
[__] up now
that the mind is so strong Let the Body
catch their mind so that's not where I'm
at so I'm always trying to reinvent the
wheel and see what I'm capable of next
we live in a world that's so busy and so
active and moving so fast right now I am
sitting with Tom Ferry
my mind is sitting with Tom Ferry yeah
it's not talking to Tom Ferry about
thinking about my God I can order some
more books I'm sorting out of here I'm
doing this I'm doing that that's the
first thing about visualization yeah you
must make sure to silence out all the
of life which is very hard to do and
it's very hard because your visual
picture must be clear
it has to be clear it can't be like kind
of in and out like a like a fuzzy TV you
gotta see it it has to become real you
get to take a snapshot of it a million
times put in the bank
that snapshot of me was getting that
4021 pull-up yeah knocked out because
the record was four thousand twenty I
visualized that over and over and over
again I visualized what I was going to
say because a guy's name was Stephen
Highland I was thinking like what you're
going to say to him on video where I
finally got his ass yep so I visualized
success
but then I went through
that's the that's the fun part yeah
I have to do
4020 pull-ups to get to that 4021
pull-up I know now because it took me
three chances to get it all those
failures
they were great for me to examine where
I was at along the way so I take all
that and I and I put in the bank as far
as visualization okay when I get to 2500
pull-ups my hands start to rip
okay get ready for that so I started
visualizing how am I going to handle the
pain okay then you start visualizing
okay my my nutrition was off
you start visualizing all these things
because you have to mimic it a million
times but I can't mimic 4020 pull-ups by
doing it but you can see all the
Milestones while you fails right and see
yourself going Beyond it that's right
yeah so that that was my big thing about
I had to walk in get the chalk see I had
to see everything over and over and over
again and when I realized I had to keep
that visual that picture in my head for
17 hours it took me 17 hours to break
that record so for 17 hours well it used
to be loud everywhere I went I put these
headphones in yeah I never listen to
music by listening to One song Going the
Distance you know for 17 hours it's two
minutes and 13 seconds yeah for 17 hours
I had that in that's a lot of Rocky a
lot of Rocky and I just went here yeah
for and so I was able to visualize every
rep yeah so I visualize my hand
placement making sure that felt right
before I got going I didn't ignore all
the little pains my hands got sweaty
okay that means I was aware of
everything that means my okay my hand's
about to rip it's getting sweaty wipe it
off be aware everything I was totally in
the moment because of how I visualized
everything so whenever times got hard my
mind said you're not good enough right
let's go right so
my mind wasn't my eyes my mind weren't
connecting right
so how do you combat that so how you
combat that is this I call it the cookie
jar okay
you have to remind yourself we all have
a story we've all all of us have gone
through very hard times
but we were we were in a hard time
our mind has a way of forgetting what
all we've overcome I have a way of
taking one second when I want to quit
and said okay
you endured this so I look at my life
and how I came up as the ultimate
training ground versus most people look
at it as why woe is me God why exactly
why right I had to flip this upside down
and say hang on a second
God was training me to be born the
baddest men on the planet absolutely
right that's how he this was this was my
journey like for instance in hell week
yeah they said when you get to Wednesday
of hell week you're broken so everybody
on Wednesday but give them contacts
you're talking about 72 hours 30 hours
of training yeah it starts on Sunday
ends on Friday and on Wednesday you're
almost done halfway through yeah so
everybody on Wednesday they hear this
because everybody says Wednesday is like
man you're so tired you're done so that
becomes your new Norm yeah
no you're cruising into Wednesday
getting ready to feel tired when you
don't even know why because someone told
you you could feel tired bingo so for me
I was like hang on a second I started
studying my mind a whole bunch while
growing up facing these things don't
listen to anybody's dialogue but your
own they're tired they're not you yeah
so is this all about it's just your mind
has a tactical advantage over you at all
times it knows your weaknesses it knows
your strengths and it will guide you
into your nice comfort zone yeah we had
to reprogram our mind to get it did it
like a different vantage point so then
you know how to be in charge of yourself
yep versus your mind being in charge of
you everybody thinks I'm the world's
toughest right because if I just talk
about I broke the pull-up record I I did
all these races I went through seal
trail with you I was in three hell weeks
Ranger school let's talk about all the
badassery like we like to do on social
media and I don't tell you that I was a
kid and I was scared and I was depressed
and insecure and and all the
what good am I for anybody right I'm a
superhero I'm a liar
I'm that now but I wasn't born that yeah
I had to make myself into this when I
was in the worst time my life in hell
week I looked at everybody
and said I'm the most trained person
here well that's the truth I've gone
through more mental torture than any
walk even fathom yeah so I'm looking at
the baddest people on the planet I'm
looking at them like this
you guys can't hold a stick so I started
looking at verses like I don't belong
here versus like
I might be the bad person ever come here
wow
wow who could have
pulled this off who could have been
given a sewer to live in in their mind
and say okay at Birth I'm gonna put you
in the worst place on the planet Earth
and let me see if you can go to the top
of the mountain right with nothing right
but just hard work grit and figuring it
out and not putting yourself back in the
dungeon every time something got hard so
that's what became my daily voice was
you really are the baddest person on the
planet after a period of time
you start to believe that right so I
worked with a few pictures I won't name
their names big name pictures
and I studied them for a long time I
want to be better man I want to be
better I want to be better so I I got
film on it I studied them I studied okay
what is wrong
that's it
I saw it
whenever something bad would happen
on the mound that's the first thing they
would do totally the head drops
shoulders roll forward they look down
that sends a direct message to your
brain that I failed I am a failure that
starts the downward spiral to being a
failure on that mileage you can't even
recover yeah
is that so I started teaching this it's
that person who you throw a bad pitch
you get the ball back your chin is not
high because that shows that you're way
too proud your chin stays here your
shoulders stay nice and level your feet
firmly on the ground your hands planted
like I'm ready to beat somebody's ass
and I'm ready for battle it tells your
mind
wow
maybe we didn't that bad we're still in
the fight so that's the one thing I
always do is like even if I
yeah keep your body position like you're
still a woman like you're still fighting
if you get a hundred bad calls in a row
yep
hello I'm David Goggins how you doing
today yep
okay wrong one
don't start getting poopy pants to get
upset with yourself no it's a mentality
and your body language has a direct
thing to your brain and how it functions
every day I tell myself
I used to believe I was the weakest man
that God ever created so now I believe
that I'm the hardest human being that
God ever made
I don't care if it's true or not it's
the most important conversation to me
it's the thing that drives me every day
it is it's the one thing that keeps me
going every day is that you must
constantly be that man that you want to
be so before I start this journey be
Navy SEAL I go back to see my dad
because I realize now I got fixed
I'm blaming everything I gotta go back
you know how a lot of times you're like
if you're a runner your your your right
knee may hurt but it's not your right
neither hers is where your left hip yes
but we're constantly on the right knee
I'm concentrating all my
but I need to go back to the root of the
problem which is my dad I gotta face the
demon so I go back and I and I go back
in as a as an older man now I'm in my
20s I'm not a kid anymore and I want to
see this man and face him as a as a as a
grown man
but still as a kid in my head I was
still a kid I was a grown man as my age
I went back and I realized he was the
same man that he was still the same
still the same and I talked to him he
was still nuts and um but I I had to go
back and face that one more time but to
face it in a different way how'd you do
it different
I looked at him in a way we never said
sorry to one another and he went off
about my mom and my grandparents and all
kind of I looked at him in a way that I
realized now
why you what's up
I had to almost be him
to realize it's okay brother
it's okay because I realized that
somewhere in your life something you up
and you didn't deal with it and so you
put that on me my mom everybody around
you I'm gonna deal with my
wow so even though you gave me all this
you you gave me a satchel of I didn't
deserve and now I'm all [__] up and
people think I'm a liar you gave me this
you created this nightmare of Goggins
I'm gonna fix it though
I saw these Navy Seals before I became
one my God they're better than me yeah
they're better me I gave up a hundred
sets
and I had to work up to realize these
are human beings
with the same [__] I have yeah this some
people could run faster swim better but
mentality is mentality yeah there's no
you're not gonna not work me so I'm
gonna catch up somewhere yep so that
being said
I used all that 300 pound man that fat
guy that dumb guy and people say why you
say dumb you have to be real with
yourself you got to be wrong if you're
not smart you're dumb but you can become
smart you can become smart it's not a
permanent tag you're dumb forever yeah
you're fat forever no be raw don't find
the cushy word
I'm a big guy in visualizing I'm a big
guy in making a world it may not exist
to me it does
and
I'm overpowering myself every day and
you gotta find tools to do that that's
the tool that I use
so that's what it's all about I have a
good living now for me where I'm at in
my life
I was out on a fire in Colorado
and we were digging fire line on this
like 50 like it was like on the side of
a dad going up Mountain yeah and we're
trying to keep the fire from moving
we're digging this fire line 14 inches
or my fault 18 inches wide three miles
long 12 of us digging and it is the
hardest work you make 12 dollars an hour
okay nothing you set up your shop like
when you're done digging you pretty much
lay down you go to sleep and you get up
you dig some more really status for two
weeks long what are you digging it's
like a whole line so you're trying to
get down to to a mineral source so
you're trying to get down to the to the
Earth so so that if that fire is moving
it can't burn dirt really so you're
moving fuels got it you're you know so
so not only are you digging you're
cutting down trees it's hard work but
the moral story is I'm 43 don't need to
do it at all this is why I do you're
making money I'm making money I I I have
a good life
I don't need to do it
and everybody asks me why I do it this
is why
the 21 year old kid was out there
and he wanted a pair of running shoes
it's all he wanted was pair of running
shoes
60 70 100 bucks or whatever you know
easy for us yeah 100 shoes
he looked up at the mountain
that we had been on for days digging
this fire line
and he said that would take me five or
six hours of work to buy those shoes
except I'm not gonna buy them
it's the perspective of life that
perspective of life right there
of that is the value that we lose
when things start to come so easy in
life
it's the perspective that 21 year old
had and looked about that mountain and
thought he looked at his hands he looked
at the at the amount of hours of pulling
that Pulaski that that tool and raking
that ground and then cutting those trees
and moving them and that hours of work
he looked at his feet and said these old
shoes would do
um
it's that perspective in life that we
lose
and that's that story that most people
may not mean anything
it's that story I always want to have in
my life
that you cannot lose perspective
of where you've come in life because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some incredible success motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there here's the hard
truth about getting great it takes time
and dedication it takes a willingness to
accept that you're not yet good enough
it takes the ability to stare at the
places that you know that you're weak